if you get into a sauna the way i just
described not the two hours a day but 30
minutes
twice a week or three times per week you
reduce the likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event by 27 percent
if you do it four or more times per week
you reduce the probability of dying by
50 percent is there any scientific
evidence that being naked is beneficial
in the sauna well in certain contexts it
leads to um childbirth okay well i'll
have to read up on that i think dorothy
parker said
the cure for boredom is curiosity
there's no cure for curiosity
the following is a conversation with
andrew huberman his third time on this
podcast
he's a brilliant neuroscientist at
stanford university and the host of one
of the best
the best if you ask me health and
science podcast in the world called
hubermann lab podcast
check him out on instagram twitter and
youtube
most importantly andrew is a great human
being and has quickly become a great
friend
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's andrew
huberman
we meet again my friend uh we should
talk on each other's podcast once a year
i think we should make a deal
i was just talking to the guys this show
called louis i don't know if you know it
and okay yeah with louis ck
and there's this thing called bang bang
which people are probably watching know
exactly what i'm talking about it's this
worst possible thing you can do in terms
of meals which is you go to a restaurant
do a full meal
and then go to another restaurant and do
a full meal and you pat
that's exactly brutal so they go
mexican italian sushi pizza barbecue i
hope that that one is disgusting this
kind of thing reminds me
of the joy of food
last time we were hanging out we went we
went to see joe do comedy and then we
went to eat russian food yeah and it was
a particularly
experience to
go to a russian restaurant i was the
only
person there that didn't speak russian
yeah and eat russian food with you and
um
because i felt walking in they they
trusted you
they didn't trust me yeah the funny
thing about the the people there they
were talking to you in russian and then
they refused to sort of uh switch to
english even though they understood you
speak no russian this is russian house
in austin by the way
uh anyway what
by way of question what's the worst or
or the best depending on your
perspective cheat meal let's call it a
pigging out meal but it could be a cheat
meal uh that you've ever had or you want
to have that's like on the bucket list
or something that's in the past like
where you did the something like a bang
bang which is like you're talking about
multiple thousands of calories
that you just feel horrible about
yourself but you still keep eating
because it's delicious
but also great company
something about the atmosphere is just
right
screw the diet screw all the things you
know just
like you should be doing but just throw
it all out the window i've done that
several times yeah i don't do this
anymore but um the entire time i was a
postdoc so five years and the entire
time i was a pre-tenured professor so
five years so
i
basically followed the
tim ferriss slow carb diet which is you
know people can look it up but it worked
really well it was basically
some you know like good animal proteins
you know fish and meat and things like
that low carbohydrates
like low glycemic stuff is mostly
lentils and beans and things and
vegetables no no dairy no
um anyway but then why in there sorry to
interrupt no no pasta so it wasn't low
carb it was low glycemic carb and i did
that and it worked terrifically well
just for energy levels because i want to
be able to train and work and then one
day a week
you're supposed to go
full cheat day
and so i would do what used to be 12
hours but then it became 24 you know you
start to redefine what the day is
and i would
and that was when costello was
pretty young and we would do it together
so i would get pizzas and croissants and
donuts and i would just do the full
thing and by the end of the day you
don't want to look at an item of food
you're just repulsed by food the only
modification i made was the next day i
would fast completely just to avoid the
gastric distress of eating anything
and um so i would do them on sundays and
then mondays i'd fast all day and then
by tuesday i felt pretty good again but
sunday and monday or
you just feel like you're sliding down
the slope of just
blood sugar disaster terrible idea or a
good idea you know at the time i enjoyed
it i love donuts croissants all that
kind of stuff what's interesting is
after
stopping that whole protocol now i just
try and eat well
that's really a protocol now i basically
i do a pseudo intermittent fasting i
don't i'm not really strict but i'll
start it eating around 11. eat my first
meal around 11. i usually train in the
morning eat my last bite of food
somewhere around eight or nine and i'm
not super strict i might have some
berries or something late at night three
meals two meals
two two two meals and then maybe a
little bit of snacking on some nuts or
something in the middle ever fast 24
hours never done a long fast except when
i was doing the the chickpeas and then
um
and actually there are a couple
different ways to do cheat days that
were fun like if you were in a new city
you could try all the
restaurants that you wanted yeah and i
think tim and our mutual friend john
romanello did a i think it was like a
cheat day marathon where they did you
know marathon's 26.3 miles they went to
26.3 different locations in new york
they put it on a map and i never took it
to that extreme but
wait wait yeah over how many days one
day that was their what
just because they were you know just a
little bit of something at each place
yeah exactly i mean there are things
that guys do in their 30s that you just
shouldn't do in your 40s i can say that
because i'm in my 40s and uh now i just
try and eat well most days and what's
interesting is about 12 to 14 months ago
i completely lost all appetite for
sweets i don't know what happened i
still love savory food so meat and
butter and cheese
and i love vegetables too i love fruit
also but lost all appetite so if you put
a donut in front of me or ice cream or
something like i just it's it's almost
aversive to me and i don't know what
happened i don't know what changed it's
probably a scientific explanation sure
it says to do neurons dementia
[Laughter]
the sugar
the uh the desire for that rush maybe is
gone
from your uh from your soul so what was
the most delicious thing is the
croissant doughnuts what what is there a
thing that um there's a place in uh
portland i don't know if it's still open
called little teas bakery
and they have croissants that easily
rival the croissants in paris people
make a lot of the pastry in paris but
it's really the bread in paris that's
amazing we lived there when i was a kid
and we did a sabbatical there and you
know there they do the baguette morning
bake and afternoon bake and there's
nothing like the bread in paris um or
the people you know and
but if you're in the if you're in the
pacific northwest you know you can find
amazing croissants there what do you do
with the croissant what do you do with
the bread butter or is it just i
actually used to i don't eat them
anymore i don't have much of an appetite
for them even though they're not a sweet
food but um i'm always putting butter on
the croissant
butter on the butter croissant no jam i
would never i would never adulterate my
croissant i have to actually be honest
about this because people talk about
steak and they talk about bread with
butter i feel like butter is cheating i
feel like you're disrespecting the
fundamental food
by adding butter because butter it's
like it's like it's like a
elite
version of ketchup
you're there we diverge because for me
bread is just a vehicle for butter
a cracker is just a vehicle for cheese
oh so that's just the the cracker and
the bread is just texture it's just that
people look at you funny if you if you
just eat the butter straight which
occasionally i do i got it but so i put
a little piece of bread underneath it
not because i'm a low carb strictly low
carb but just because otherwise you get
some funny looks um that's like pasta is
a vehicle for pasta sauce
it's interesting but like indian
non-bread you have uh you have the bread
i i've had a lot of soul searching on
which part of indian is brings me so
much joy is it the bread or is it all
the sauces that come with the bread well
there we diverge again because for
whatever reason
and no disrespect to anyone but indian
food doesn't appeal to me well you're a
lucky man because the
the number of calories in that food it
sneaks like non-bread i don't know how
non-bread is made but i think it's just
soaked in
oil and it just very intensely like the
density of calories is very very high
for me barbecue i would say is probably
the that's good anytime i'm in austin i
start thinking about barbecue i do love
you know i do love me my dad's argentine
i mean i love steak i love meat i mean
argentina chorizo sausage is an
appetizer before you have steak
so it's meat on top of meat and it's not
just you know it's not just the men
right you see women sometimes very
petite women eating steaks that are
bigger than their
their skull size yeah slowly they eat
very slowly there and they all eat
dessert too which is interesting and
they generally do this sort of one meal
per day and do that kind of reflexively
that's how i think about it because i
often eat one meal a day especially when
i'm traveling it feels like a cheap meal
because it allows it gives you a bit of
more freedom
to just lose yourself in the quantity of
the food i did the three day fast and i
ate uh chicken breast like literally
chicken breast with nothing else just
grilled and it was the most delicious
piece of meat i've ever eaten and that
uh and that gives you the problem is
when you fast for three days you really
can't pig out you really shouldn't you
because your stomach will shrink in size
already your gut microbiome is almost
completely depleted by fasting a lot of
people think oh cleanses and fasts are
great for the microbiome they quash your
microbiome however when you start eating
again the microbiome comes back better
than it was before you're fast for
people who don't know sergey and todd
are on the call they're kind of pulling
stuff up they just pulled up
phelps with the i forgot how many
calories he was eating 10 000. you know
what's interesting there's some some
cool physiology around this the reason
he needed to eat so much is not that he
was burning that many calories
in pure movement it's that when you do
exercise in water even if it's warm
water the heat transfer in water is
greater so you burn far more calories
and again here i'm admittedly lifting
that from
knowledge that was passed on to me by
tim ferriss that i did so but i checked
it out and it's absolutely true so if
you exercise in water even if it's not
really cold water your caloric needs go
way up which is why you get out of the
pool and you're often really hungry and
for fans of the human lab podcast and if
you're not a fan what what what are you
doing with your life uh you would
probably chuckle at the fact that uh
andrew just cited his sources even on
that statement
because you're so good at i don't know
how your memory works but
um the only person whose memory is
better than joe rogan is yours but my
colleagues joke um you know
pubmed sort of scrolls through through
my through my mind um also in science as
you know attribution is so baked into
what we do
and um and i think that it's interesting
because now spending a lot of time on
social media attribution is not as
common and um but in academia you learn
really early on that if you give a talk
about your data and you cite all these
amazing sources all it does is
make you look better right whereas in
social media and elsewhere in the
business sector it's almost like citing
other people people feel as if it's
going to take away some of the credit
all it does is place you in the company
of people that do really nice work so i
have tremendo and i have genuine and
tremendous respect for tim he's been
about 10 years ahead on a huge number of
health related things and other things
an extremely kind person very thoughtful
person so it's also just a pleasure to
shine light on other people yeah well i
actually to push back i i know there's a
culture
of if you write a paper
standing on the shoulders of giants is a
powerful thing
but there's also a culture of not giving
credit
to the strongest idea in your paper and
instead say it's kind of or imply that
it's original
there is a culture of kind of not
celebrating others i think people
get most competitive in all walks of
life but especially in science when
they're as the closer they get and
exactly the thing they work on
and so there's this dance you know
there's a few researchers
in each of the individual little things
that you work on
if you're studying a particular kind of
ant you know that other [ __ ]
that also studying that particular ant
and then you're not going to often give
credit for the brilliant ideas that that
other researcher is doing and i think
one of the things you've discovered and
just as part of your nature and which is
why it's it's really great that you've
uh have an audience and you inspire
others to do the same as you celebrate
that other ant study here it's great and
you everybody wins it raises all boats
but that initial instinct to be like uh
what is it in borat like my neighbor my
neighbor gets a
a toaster i get a bigger toaster
yeah that mindset to you know it's not
that i'm not
competitive in certain domains but um
yeah i get great pleasure from um
sharing things that i find and um
i think that you know at the end of the
day
you're as strong as your community
and
you can build a wonderful community just
by
pointing out things that you love like
these are all just loves i see a paper i
love it only rarely do i think i wish we
had done that i usually think fantastic
now i can just focus on something else
because they checked off that box
and by the way you mentioned pubmed and
and barbecue i i should mention that i
got a chance to hang out with uh rick
rubin thanks to you he's a friend of
yours and you made the connection that
was a huge gift to my
spirit i guess he's a truly truly
special human being and
the there's a lot i could say about why
he's a special human being i'd love to
learn how you met him but i should also
just mention on the pubmed thing
it was so interesting talking to him
about music
and uh both on the podcast and privately
and just listening to music together
because
when you mention a song
he does this thing where he like closes
his eyes
and he finds that song in the album that
we're talking about and he steps through
the album you could see the brain like
stepping through individual songs to
find that song in the album there's that
kind of look up process and then he puts
himself mentally in that space of like
okay this is uh you know
whatever the album is and not just the
ones he produced but
all he's an encyclopedia of
of music and it's so interesting
it also uh the thing i really
love about something like a calmness
that radiates from him that's okay to
close your eyes
and place yourself in in the in the
place where that album was recorded
in the feeling of that album
and like that that silence let's go
there let's go there together it's like
alice in wonderland and we'll go there
together you do a good rick rubin minus
the beard minus the beard his beard is
epic right you can't fake a beard like
that you know how'd you guys meet
yeah well rick i'm very blessed to
consider a close friend um rick and i
got introduced through a common friend
during the pandemic and we started doing
some face time together and just talking
about things related to science and
health and i i'm not a musician i have
no musical ability or talent i have a
good ability to memorize lyrics and i
love lyrics and i love poetry so i asked
him a lot of questions about musicians
that i happen to love that he's worked
with and knows and so he would give me
stories about musicians and i would talk
to him about
health and then eventually we formed a
friendship where we would talk about any
number of different topics in life
and then we started spending time
together in person uh when he was in
town or nearby and
as you now know
you know rick
in addition to all his incredible
accomplishments has an incredible
understanding
of
how to
get the brain and body into state right
and as you pointed out
he's willing to
do the things that allow him to help
these incredible artists get into the
best state to do their craft
and so if he needs to sit there and be
quiet with his eyes closed for a minute
or two and or more
he'll do that
he has routines to allow himself to get
into state and it's really inspired me
to think about
states of mind as something that you
know we'd all love to just just flip the
switch and say we're focused or we're
creative but um to actually
ratchet through the the challenging
steps in order to do that and to figure
out what one needs to do on a regular
basis to get into a proper state it's
not just going to come from a cup of
coffee
a you know a
lamp of a particular wavelength or
something it's going to be those things
but it's also going to be really
teaching oneself how to get into proper
state yeah you did an episode on
hypnosis do you think it's a kind of
self-hypnosis yes i do um because
hypnosis is a
con you limit the context you're very
alert
and you're very calm
and um he has a number of these
different practices and so we would talk
about those and then we also have
enjoyed a lot of discussions about deep
neuroscience in fact i introduced rick
to a friend of mine who's a neurosurgeon
and neuroscientist and they've become
friendly you know rick is one of these
people that he sort of defies definition
um incredibly kind incredibly private
person too so you know i'm being
respectful of that but um and then of
course uh he's a fan of your podcast and
so when i learned that i i it just made
natural sense to introduce you and i
know he really enjoyed meeting you and
we talk about you a lot and of course in
a positive light you know i think his
dedication to getting into these states
of mind and his willingness to do that
has completely transformed my routines
around life like for instance before
doing a very long podcast recording the
solo ones which often take me several
hours or more six hours to record
sometimes more sometimes less i realize
that there's a certain brain state
associated with that so i have to really
limit the kind of interactions i have
for the two hours before
i actually walk and talk out loud
through my neighborhood people think i'm
crazy but i live in a neighborhood where
there are a lot of crazy
creatives anyway saying you're not crazy
well um at least not uh institutionally
defined as crazy yet but um you know
getting into state of mind is something
that we'd all just imagine would flip
the switch but rick really convinced me
you have to do the work to do the work
can you maybe uh
linger on that lucid day a little bit
more your process of how you get in that
space that's really interesting because
i i have to admit
i do everything last minute before
podcast i don't know
uh like there's a lot of anxiety because
like whatever if i have to pack if i
have to set up stuff
you were luckily a few minutes you
showed up a few minutes later which for
an academic is right on the right on
time
but the stress is immense
and uh
on top of that you look at like a
situation with rick rubin
he's out i had to set up microphones in
front of him
and just that stress the anxiety he
knows a lot about microphones what do
you say which i really loved he's like
how close
do you like
the microphone to be
it's like that's a very rick rubin kind
of thing right that the details really
matter yeah the details really matter
right down to
your relationship to the microphone
right yeah distance and whether or not
it brings out the timbre in your voice
but of course that's what he does he he
produces music but he also said like
you know he is the professional
he said
how close do you like it to be and he
said it with the gentleness where i had
like an existential crisis where i don't
i don't know i
he gave me so much like
wow like he made me feel like an artist
like that the microphone uh distance is
a decision you're supposed to make well
i have to say and this has actually come
up in some of our conversations about
you i mean you are you are an artist and
actually joe rogan
once i heard him talking about
podcasting and the fact that he's always
trying to get better at it you know and
he described podcasting at one moment as
an art right and it is it's a certain
medium of communication and there's a
cadence and a rhythm that um when it's
working it really can facilitate the
transfer of information when it's not it
doesn't i mean obviously joe just being
himself has tapped into that cadence
that allows and it's made so many people
excited to hear him talk well in his
case and in general i think part of the
art
is uh refusing the world as you get a
bigger audience
change who you are there's one quote
that i've seen out there where he says
you know i'm like the
talking about himself he says you know
i'm like the fish that got through the
net there's no stage version of me right
how he is
in person is how he is
you know out in the world and of course
there's nuance to his life right and his
different um relationships of course but
it's true i mean we've had the you know
the great fortune of spending time with
him out away from the microphones so to
speak
joe is joe
so can you
speak to your that process you mentioned
the walking and the talking to yourself
because that's fascinating yeah i try
and
do a couple of things um
first of all i when i was a kid i had a
little bit of a grunting tick
when i was five or six
i would feel this build up of tension in
my throat
and i would do this grunting tick if i
get very tired i start to do it still we
actually know that this is related to
these basal ganglia circuits for go no
go you've got an accelerator and a break
basically in your neural circuitry and
um kids with turrets in ocd
um the break doesn't work quite as well
and so one thing that happens is if i
wake up in the morning and i'm
especially if i'm well rested
well if i'm not well rested i do a
hypnosis or yoga nidra in order to
recover my sleep that works really well
but then once i'm into the process of
preparing the podcast
i've already gone through my notes i
know what i want to say more or less in
a kind of general contour and then i
take a walk
and i
i try to so no phone with me and i try
to assess
whether or not my energy is too high or
too low for podcasting because when you
podcast as you know you have to punch
out a lot of material but then there's
times when you really need to slow down
and emphasize and articulate
and so uh what i do uh this is i don't
i've never revealed this uh what i do
actually is i will recite the lyrics of
songs for about 10 minutes
um songs i love while i walk out loud it
calms you and focuses you what does it
do i think it gets my vocal cords
warmed up
and it also do you sing or speak them i
often sing them
and unfortunately nobody hears and as i
do this i start to evaluate whether or
not i'm straining to get the words out
or whether or not i'm straining
to
make them slow enough so that i can
articulate them
so there are days when i have so much
energy
that i
i'm trying to speak faster than i should
in order to articulate properly there
are other days when i'm tired and i
can't sort of keep up with my thoughts
and so what i try and do is assess that
and then
adjust the transmission the rpm so to
speak for instance i can speak very
quickly and then i can slow down so i
can change the cadence of my voice and
when you teach in the classroom you
learn as you know because you're an
excellent teacher i've watched your
lectures in the classroom as you teach
in the classroom when you want to slow
down
every teacher knows you turn to the
whiteboard or chalkboard and you start
writing right it gives you a break and
then you turn around and you fire back
the kind of machine gun fire of of
information and then you slow down or
you underline something when you podcast
you don't have that opportunity right
there no visuals in my podcast so
what i try and do is always
get my voice warmed up and make sure
that i'm thinking and speaking at
approximately the same rate
and then i also do this thing as i put
my vision into panoramic vision when i
walk which is very calming
and then i actually start to
remind myself of the purpose of
podcasting this sounds very mission
statement-e but you asked what i do
i i remind myself first
and foremost that what i want to
communicate what i want to come through
is the beauty and utility of biology and
i only feel comfortable saying the word
beauty publicly now
about science things thanks to you
because uh i i think love and beauty
yeah life
love and beauty dr andrew huberman love
and beauty um but also darkness and
hatred and uh if you're talking about
the lex friedman podcast you have to
adjust you have to address the shadow
also the shadow side but i think about
the i want to communicate the
the beauty and utility of biology and
then i i check my my emotional state i
want to make sure that i'm not angry
about anything
and certainly if i am that i'm going to
set it aside for the podcast because
that's not a place for for my whatever i
might be dealing with i also really
start to feel into the parts of the
research and the papers i found that i
really love
because that's the part of me that
i i like the most frankly um
and
on the podcast if there's a paper like
for instance we have a paper excuse me a
podcast coming out soon about um heat as
a tool you know sauna but some other
things and in researching this i learned
so much about
these heat shock proteins and the use of
sauna in finland for increasing growth
hormone but also for the treatment of
mental illness and i realized i i fell
in love with this literature it's just a
beautiful literature these people are
true pioneers for doing this work now
everyone's in the sauna but this was 20
years ago the way the experiments were
done were amazing with all these finnish
people with thermocouples up there
rectum to measure temperatures swimming
in pools it's hilarious and great and so
i start to think about i think
you know i just start to really access
my love of the work and then when we
finally sit down
meaning my producer rob and i and record
i just sort of want to just bask in in
sharing it just like the little version
of me when i was six or seven i used to
spend all weekend reading the
encyclopedia guinness book of world
records making my mother drive me places
to introduce me to i had this obsession
with trapping animals when i was a kid
meet these people and then on monday i
would insist on giving a
lecture in class which is a little kid
so that's basically what it is i just
try and access that that child-like
energy and um so i want to be clear
the goal is always to make the
information
interesting clear
and actionable and if it's also
surprising then then that's a bonus but
that's basically the process but yeah
i'm i'm singing and talking and and
getting into state and i used to feel
very uh sheepish about sharing any of
this is the first time i've ever shared
it out loud but but rick was the one who
encouraged me to
find a process that works and continue
to develop that process and not let
anything get near that process people in
my personal life know this and when it's
time it's like i don't care what else is
going on on i'm i'm moving into that
brain state and there's probably a
process like that for anything that you
do in life that you take seriously so
the people that have perfected this is
athletes like if olympic level athletes
they have to have a process like this
you know i think tiger woods actually
was
taught self-hypnosis quite young
um and used self-hypnosis often during
his tournaments sometimes to great
uh success and other times less so is
there other
places in life
that you use
kind of a protocol like a mental
protocol to get ready
many of the best areas of life are their
own form of hypnosis right um true you
know that you're in hypnosis if for
instance you're in a movie and something
happens and you feel the emotional lift
without being self-conscious about it um
yes i think that um
one thing that we've tried to do in our
house is around meal times to try and
set a state
that food isn't just something that we
just throw down our our throats and i'm
fortunate that you know my partner cooks
really well and so i try and give her
the space to do that and it that's a
whole thing of her getting into state
and then for the cooking though for the
cooking the preparation i can just see
it i just see the way she approaches the
whole thing and the the pleasure in
serving it and and i'm an eater not a
cooker um
but both are important roles you could
be a very good eater like
there's something about is there
anything better in this world than that
feeling especially if it's a family
getting around a table
just the warmth of that
i don't know the
it's like uh the cold outside
of the the cruel world cannot touch you
in this place that you've returned to
and if uh
i mean did you grow up eating meals as a
family yeah yeah i mean sitting down no
television
no well i didn't really have television
period uh
uh
outside of meals
so most of my time was spent
um
you know like a stray cat
outdoors just running around
playing soccer imagine you in this like
dirt or concrete lot between two very
high-rise buildings playing soccer yeah
in uh in like athletic gear that you
only see in eastern europe you know how
like you come to the states and people
wear their athletic gear you go to
europe and you see
maybe it's the soccer culture yeah but
you see athletic gear that you just
don't see anywhere else that's
interesting i mean i
we grew up pretty poor so
first of all i was always wearing my
brother's who's an older brother
brother's clothes
uh and they were like
old
uh
like my favorite things were american
things that i didn't understand it would
be like a pepsi shirt or something and
it was just
that was the gear and it was like too
large for me but i thought i was the
coolest person ever just wearing this
fancy like kanye
like type of fashion yeah there's
something about i feel like in in uh
eastern europe they wear athletic gear
where like the guys just like zip up
yeah no that's like fancy stuff that's a
few like those are the cool kids i see
like the cool soccer players uh football
players that uh
like they were in a league of some kind
so they would get uniforms or like or
they somehow
i always thought anyone who had anything
nice
had to do something really bad to get it
that was my way that's the view of the
world because like
um like i guess i didn't understand
how it's it's possible to be rich
because most of us were surrounded by
people who were poor and that life was
beautiful and simple it's like why do
you escape that life but you still
admire the the cool like uh
when we got mcdonald's it was like
what kind of world
does this place come from like who
invented this
this it's a fascinating view from a
child's perspective of like of
capitalism essentially yeah but but the
fact you ate dinner together is really
interesting
my parents divorced when i was an
adolescent so then there was a total
fracture of any family structure but
prior to that we ate dinner together
every night i was expected to know how
to use my knife and fork and you know
it's like a
very um structured thing
i don't know if kids do that now um you
know if i ever have kids they're going
to do that
and certainly
actually on the way over here i was
thinking i was like you know uh i really
want a lot of kids i wanted like a whole
litter and um i was thinking if lex has
kids and i have kids then like then we
can
we can like pit them against each other
with jiu jitsu this is my chance at
redemption
the long game
right they'll all want to be engineers
or physicists yeah um they won't want to
be biologists um
but but in all seriousness i i look
forward to the day that our our kids uh
play together yeah yeah i think there's
something
so the family dinner the ritual of the
family dinner like but also the special
occasion dinners like uh
where there's a little bit more
preparation a little bit more cooking
whether it's on the weekend or for some
holiday
in russia it was
a thing that actually i find completely
missing for the most part
in america is there was neighbors there
was a
you broke the walls between families
much more commonly
like there would be kind of regular
characters like a sitcom almost you know
if you watch the sitcom it's never just
the family there's always like other
characters it's bursting in the door
bursting in the door let's start doing
that here just to make you feel at home
just start showing up
i know where you live i think people
want to respect uh like uh you know
michael mouse lives next door to me and
i think people want to respect each
other's privacy or something like that
and i think
we all get super busy and you know
like
it's kind of work to do this
uh dinner together
or you know you know if you see it as a
thing that needs to be scheduled it's
work we get busy there's a lot of stuff
going on but if it's part of a ritual a
part of the culture
the the all all of those walls get
broken down and then you realize like
that's like later looking back those are
the things you miss it's like that's
what that's what life is about like all
the stupid stuff you're doing in terms
of career whatever
all the busy things those don't matter
what matters it's the people and yeah in
academia you know
this changed in the last few years of
course um but one of the great joys was
professors will stop by your office or
your lab nobody said set up an
appointment there's a guy when i was a
professor in san diego a guy named
harvey kearney's member of the national
academy is the the truly the world's
expert in the evolution of vision and
evolution of brains generally and he
would show up in my lab and he was just
start talking to the students in
postdocs
and um
i mean in a pure encyclopedia
and then you'd at some point you'd say
hey harvey i gotta go and you you kick
him out right or this guy he's a
physicist david klein
david kleinfeld who's so same way
actually david kleinfeld's interesting
one he a student of his
went to on to create the beavis and
butthead cartoon and one of them is
david he's a physics professor now
people can look him up and david's one
of those guys who just walk into your
office he just sit down you just start
talking to you he's and and so there's a
kind of a family feel it's like cheers
or seinfeld or one of those shows where
somebody just walks in and uh yeah i
think you and i both share a love of the
community around things and podcasting
is a little bit more isolated um i
should say for the guest episodes
the preparation is completely different
because it's more conversational and so
there i don't do any of this business of
putting myself into state i just try and
make sure that the guest is
taken care of and i do list out the
questions i'm gonna ask before but those
i actually really like the interview
episodes far more than i like this doing
the solo ones just psychologically i
mean i just like learning from someone
directly yeah because you asking an
expert about something like sitting here
with you when we recorded the podcast
where you were a guest on the huberman
lab podcast and for the first time and
finally someone was explaining to me the
difference between machine learning
artificial intelligence and all these
other things you know and i'm i've
finally forgiven you for making me cry
about costello on camera uh but because
it helped me move through it but yeah
but in all seriousness the interview
ones are are a sheer pleasure the solo
ones i really enjoy but they're
their their work sometimes i think like
i'm going to sweat a little blood
prepping for them
well it's interesting because i do think
prepping for interviews is
having a similar process might be also
very valuable like i have to
i have to think about that because um
i think when you do a conversation
for several hours
especially when it's a high stakes one
so it's not like what you and i know
it's more like it's just chatting world
order
according to although you never know we
can different knowing you will probably
be into some pretty controversial topics
in a few minutes you like to ride the
edge more like
there are a number of topics that i just
completely avoid and my response to
those is always that i have a lot of
opinions about that but not a lot to say
you know but whereas you've become far
uh
braver in terms of the topics you'll
encounter and
some of your guests have been a bit
controversial right some of them are are
people that not a lot of people that a
lot of people don't like
um and you've been willing to just sit
down and maybe it's the jujitsu thing
you know i don't know i it is tricky one
of my goals for this year was to talk to
people
that a lot of people really don't like
are you gonna share with us
and here i am
but peop people that are in prison
right major political leaders
i've been thinking a lot about how to
talk to really difficult
controversial figures
but
find together something with them
that's deeply honest about their nature
about
the
ideas they have about the world like
reveal something real
and some people you have to be very
careful some people are very good at
hiding the reel inside them even from
themselves
that's something i think about a lot i
think about dictators of the past and i
put myself in the mindset well how do
you reveal something real
about this person to themselves i think
that to me and you kind of spoke to that
but
uh a great conversation is one one where
both of you discover something new
like uh it's not just
so i love that
too that's my favorite thing what you
mentioned which is allowing your
curiosity ask all kinds of questions and
get excited and to learn from an expert
but also
to push them to discover something about
themselves about their ideas
together and then that discovery
and sometimes it's uh uh like
we don't see it in the moment
but the audience hears it
it's weird to say like
i would compare it to when you're a
musician you're playing with other
musicians you lose yourself in the
moment yeah it's all it's like it's
working right it's working but you don't
really
uh
see the big picture
impact of what it's working right
actually feels like and that's where the
audience
uh can could see that like if you talk
to somebody evil
uh
you know for me as an interviewer i have
to empathize with that person if i want
to understand i have to put myself in
that mind space and to put yourself in
that mindset you really have to become
that you have to pl you have to
understand the evil inside of you
like you have you can't just think if
somebody's in power and has used that
power to abuse others you can't just be
a
i personally a person who seeks to
understand you can't just be a
journalist asking generic questions you
have to put yourself in a place
where you're somebody who's given a lot
of power
and slowly you start to abuse that power
and what does that person become who are
you i have to plug myself into those
moments in my life in the past where
i've been angry at something uh
and where i've been cruel because i was
angry in little ways but then you
magnify them at scale and i have to have
to go there and that's very human and
then i have to look at another person
from across the table for me and
understand well you're there too
and then you had more opportunity to do
truly cruel things and and then um
and then where like i have to plug
myself into places where i've been i can
imagine i can go where i was cruel to
others and was unaware of it
so i was in my space where i was
thinking that i'm doing good and i was
doing not good
again i've never gotten the opportunity
to do any of those things at a large
scale but all of us have done it at a
small scale sure and i plug myself into
that
and then we're we're here or two if it's
somebody who's in prison if it's
somebody who's a dictator we're in that
space where evil is
is all of us have the capacity to do
that evil and i have to imagine myself
being able to do that evil
and then we're here together in that
dark dark place
and then if it if it's just right
something real can actually come
something from that person's childhood i
may be awakening to uh
realization that i thought it was a good
person and i'm not
and
for that only happens when you truly
empathize those moments of discovery are
beautiful but they also happen in
science when you have a conversation and
you realize uh i feel like talking to
stephen wolfram i feel like we
constantly realize
beautiful things together on this
element of um
you know evil and sociopathy that you
know jung had this notion that
we have all things inside us
and that we all have the capacity to be
good or evil etc um
but i have a good fortune of working
with somebody who has deep understanding
of psychiatry but also psychoanalysis
and jungian theory and um and he said to
me recently he said you know whether or
not all people have all things inside
them is still debated in the psychology
community and in the neuroscience
community
and as a matter of philosophy but
there are certain people not many but
there are certain people for whom
they've actually lived out many versions
of their possible selves
in the first person and so those are
unique individuals then even if they
tapped into these things that as you
mentioned as a at a more minor level as
opposed to
impacting people negatively at a at
scale so being able to access those
different parts of oneself is key and
you've been willing to step into that
you know my podcast is not one in which
we we get down to those matters but yes
you never know we might do an episode on
on narcissism and sociopathy the other
thing that i took away from a
conversation with uh a friend who was a
did a lot of years in special operations
in the intelligence community he said
you know it's if you look at somebody's
past
at some point
you will come to understand some pretty
good reasons as to why they became who
they are
but you have to draw the his words the
red line someplace and what he was
referring to was the fact that certain
people at least in the eyes of certain
communities deserve to be eliminated
as a consequence of their
actions right regardless of what drove
them to those actions so it gets right
down to the line between psycho nature
nurture uh neuroscience and
the law and justice
complicated complicated themes i i can
think of a number of people that i would
love to hear you interview and here i'm
not revealing the reasons why but except
for the fact that i think you would be
uniquely suited to bring out the
important components of the conversation
that other people have not been able
to
uh do
which for instance liz holmes this is
one of the most
um
uh mysterious and yet disliked people
on the planet
um
uh she's sort of synonymous with
deception
um
i don't know if there have been any
real interviews of her since the whole
thing
um i haven't followed that case i
listened to the book and i
um i followed it a little bit because it
was happening in my hometown right
theranos was right up the road the
building's still there it's interesting
it's it's some of the most premier real
estate in silicon valley but nobody
wants it it's sort of like it's very
hard to sell a home where somebody
committed suicide or committed a murder
even if it's a beautiful home so i feel
like the theranos building is that
building um
so that would be a really interesting
interview i would love to hear that
interview one of the most interesting
dark human beings in science
yeah and then there will even be people
that say you know um was it even science
right it might have all been deception
it might have been one part deception
one part
goal setting mixed in with clearly that
there were
so many factors impacting what happened
um i think the big difference between
theranos and
that story and some of the other stories
about silicon valley where people
promised a lot more than they could
deliver is they were promising things
that were directly related to health and
health care people were taking blood
tests with the understanding that the
data they were getting was important
information about sexually transmitted
diseases and other diseases and making
real world decisions on the basis of
that whereas if you remember when the
iphone first came out
and steve jobs was still alive and the
phones were dropping calls if you held
it in a particular way and his response
was a little flip he said
hey folks it's a phone as if like don't
get so worked up but people held them
understandably to a very high standard
you know she would
sort of it seemed and i don't know
because i certainly wasn't there seemed
like she sort of
adopted this idea that you could get it
wrong a bunch of times before you get it
right
except if the allegations are true and i
think they she was found guilty i
believe on a number of accounts
that a number of the things that they
were doing were were impacting real
world decision making so steve's point
about the phone it's just a phone well
it depends on the call if you're calling
9-1-1 then it's not just a phone right
um but in the case of blood tests and
disease you know that's that's serious i
think that the theranost case was super
interesting to me because of the number
of people from major universities and
from government
that
both trusted her and the number of
people who did not trust her and yet
either didn't speak up or know and
listen to them it was only in the
forensic version of it that everyone
said oh yeah i knew that she was lying
et cetera et cetera they were lying
there are multiple people involved in
those lies apparently but i have a deep
interest in the neuroscience of of
narcissism sociopathy and some of the
darker aspects of the mind so yeah maybe
someday
maybe we'll do a podcast together yeah
and be like in the in the in the kind of
early 90s version of talk shows where we
darken the lights and we yeah we do it
together you can use your voice because
your voice is much more sinister
sounding than mine
good cop back up uh well it'd be
interesting from a scientific
perspective of somebody who is
a sociopath or psychopath
how to reveal something
real about them i think
that requires not just well i don't know
what that requires that requires the
same skill that it takes to be a good
uh therapist
right and some therapists won't work
with sociopaths because
um they don't feel any progress can be
made some therapists will work with
sociopaths because for the wealthy ones
they often
um they want their money
i i think most therapists are good and
benevolent but there are some that will
do it just same way lawyers will work
with criminals knowing they're criminals
right um
oftentimes because they're criminals
there are certain domains of psychiatry
that are
more tractable than others right
borderlines are interesting i should
just mention because they have this
phenomenon of splitting so in the in the
world of psychology the idea is that
being neurotic
is actually the goal the idea that you
could be um you know feel something and
then work a lot to overcome it or um
have some sort of defense mechanism in
place but that's not destructive that's
actually a pretty healthy state to be in
it's uh provided it's not destructive
psychotic is
truly delusional thinking about reality
and the idea is that borderline split
intermittently split between psychotic
and neurotic that's why it's called this
beautiful work by melanie klein that
describes this which i'm just now kind
of delving into but you know so the
borderline is the person who is like i
love you i love you i love you and then
truly feels as if they hate you and you
become the bad object
borderlines are challenging for
psychologists because of the splitting
right
schizophrenics are challenging because
of the the
detachment from reality and narcissists
are challenging because they're often so
charming
that even the therapists are charmed i
believe you mentioned carl deisseroth uh
we'll we'll talk he's definitely not a
narcissist he's one of the more humble
people but he is brilliant thanks again
to you
you've connected us
uh i had the pleasure of having a
conversation with him you had a
conversation with him i really enjoyed
it on the podcast you guys
come from the same science from the same
place uh maybe different journeys fast
and levels we were post-docs together
carl is truly the michael jordan the
wayne gretzky five children
amazing marriage to also an amazing
scientist his wife michelle monges in
our neurology department at stanford in
incredible thinker writer
very kind person
humble
speaking of getting into state sorry
carl i'm going to out you on this but um
carl despite being at the highest levels
of science and engineering and a
practicing psychiatrist
his office
is literally a coat closet with a small
table lamp when you meet with carl if
you manage to meet with him because he's
very hard to get to you walk in you sit
down as if you're going through some
interrogation and some spy novel
and he'll ask you
what are you most excited about lately
and i've got 11 minutes or something and
that's a meeting with carl yeah because
he's that busy but he doesn't have the
office with the pictures of the kids and
the thing and all that all that is kept
elsewhere so in order to get i asked him
why do you work in this office right you
work on light and channels of light
things related to light of all things
here you are in this dark room and he
said well this is what gets me into the
state of mind to be able to do what i
want to do very rick rubin ish
in
not at all the same person but very
similar in that he's figured out the
physical space he needs in order to get
into the optimal state to do the work
they need to do in this lifetime and
it's very unusual right if i don't have
a window i kind of freak out i can do it
here for a while we're in this black
cube here floating in space of course
but but i find that amazing that these
that these people that are operating at
this super high level are willing to
actually deprive themselves of a lot of
conditions they're not sitting there
with us with the secretary coming in
offering them espresso every five
minutes and things like no no no that's
new york neuroscience i'm picking the
new york neuroscience mafia is kind of
famous for
having all the you know
tickets to the opera and this and that
and they they enjoy lifestyle a lot the
new york new york sites oh there is one
there definitely is one they know who
they are uh they know who they are
people don't know uh
andrew huberman is from the west coast
and now he's just starting wars with the
neuroscience mafia they do amazing
science they think they they love their
lifestyle and that's wonderful but the
culture is very different yeah um
carl and i think silicon valley in
general kind of prides itself on this
kind of
um monk like a assassin right so but at
the individual scale be deliberate about
controlling the environment i think
about that with the conversations too
i haven't been deliberate about that
either in terms of controlling the space
you're in
visually yes black curtains all those
kinds of things there is nothing like
the lex friedman podcast studio
first first of all when you when you do
them remotely i always feel like i'm in
a witness relocation program
you only get the coordinates at the last
moment yeah and
you always get the sense that there are
people behind the walls that um
you know are recording things well
there's something about creating a
feeling i have a sense that there's a
robot over there there's there's
severals throughout this place and i i
think
i think part of that
part of creating a feeling would be
having the robots constantly moving
around and having a mind of their own
because that would
most closely
put guests and other humans they
interact with into a place
that's
um closest to my mind because of such an
engineering mind and and one where
when things come to life it's a
beautiful place to be and whatever that
is that could be like art but to me
robots are art and so i'm thinking about
that
both for me and for guests and and i'm
also thinking about the difficult guess
just to return to
you said elizabeth holmes one person
maybe a couple of things i want to say
so one person
i think i would like to talk to
is
galen maxwell i always get afraid right
before you reveal these kinds of things
and now i know why i get afraid yeah i
mean again
assuming that she did the things that
people claim she did
they're despicable right i mean these
were underage children right there's
just no version of the story where
she did the things
she was
accused of doing and is still a
quote-unquote good person there's just
in my mind right um and yet i think
there is tremendous interest in
understanding
like what led her to do all that so at
least for some people let me say a
couple of things so
one is
at a high level let me say that
she believes or her current story is is
that she's the victim
of who
jeffrey epstein oh my
i think i'll just leave that there
as as is so this is these are ideas that
you're facing
the nature of truth
and the nature of the human mind is what
it is and this is
imagine folks if you went into a room
with the person
that says that
what do you do next
let me also say that
i
never
or rarely let me say not say never i
rarely mention names that i'm interested
in talking to
without having made significant progress
in already securing that interview so
people sometimes ask me about vladimir
zelinski and vladimir putin
i
do not bring them up lightly
in terms of
there's in terms of there being a path
to an actual conversation that said
something i regret but i'm not sure i
know how
what to do with it but in the case of
all the people i just mentioned
i haven't been preparing for those
conversations
i only start really preparing
seriously when it's confirmed
because it's such a heavy burden
and
one of the things i regret in having
mentioned
a conversation with
vladimir putin before the war in ukraine
broke out in the past few years
is that i would mention it very loosely
very casually
and without having really deeply
put myself into a place that i'm ready
to talk to him and that that's a tricky
thing because then the internet
uh
the the audience in general and just me
when i listen back to my dumb self think
well why are you speaking so lightly
about these topics well i know you've
had a long-standing interest in
talking to him i think now you know uh
well
i don't understand um
how
i would sit down and have a conversation
with somebody like that but that's not
in
in the range of my skill sets right i or
like uh maybe not in the range of things
that you're drawn to somehow
not so much i mean i would watch that
episode with with great interest um
well you did an episode recently with
this guy who was a
former cyber criminal turned stateside
right i think he works for the
government now and there was a segment
in there
remind me his name brad johnson right
johnson there was a segment in there
where he talked about
stealing a lifetime's worth of
collected coins from some elderly woman
and this was everything she had and then
he openly admitted that he felt
no remorse
which is the way he described is purely
sociopathic and then of course we
learned that he grew up in a family
where criminal behavior was very common
it was kind of embedded into his
um notions of what typical behaviors
were and i found myself
somewhat conflicted but also hung up you
know hung up on this idea that you know
i mean he was
you know he had behaved as a sociopath
um or in a sociopathic way and it
created a an internal conflict because
he's quite charming guest and his
stories are terrific um
especially i really enjoyed his
discussions about how he would go out
and um do all these things out of a
desire to please his his girlfriend
you know so he was in service to other
people despite being a sociopath he
could say he was in service to them as a
way to extract it gets very complicated
i think is the reason i went into
science is that it at some level it's
more about facts than it is opinions and
judgments and i don't know that i have
the ability to suspend judgment over the
away from the kind of
top level contours of my initial
reaction to like
if it's true like the glenn maxwell's
and the liz holmes and the other
sociopaths is one of just kind of
revulsion and repulsion
but that could also reflect the fact
that i'm not as you know
uh neurologically sophisticated as
somebody that can spin all the plates of
of
empathy
forget forgiveness but also
um
holding people accountable the same time
that's that's work that takes if you
think about that's three forebrain
circuits having to work in parallel
that's the difference between chess or a
game of go and a game of checkers i
guess i'm playing checkers playing chess
no so one is actually holding in your
mind and two is the the raw skill of
conversation you're you're very just
having listened to your interviews
you're very good at conversation but the
skill of conversation is really tricky
i'm not being self-deprecating i'm being
just objective
i'm not
good at conversation
i'm working very hard
getting better at it i'm i'm speaking
not
about just podcasting i'm speaking just
normal life
i i'm i have anxiety
from social interaction i do you really
a huge amount yeah so this is
interesting because i never
detect that in you ever and i think uh
there are people that we both know
that have said to me that they too
feel
anxious and yet
your voice is steady
i don't see any perspiration oh yeah um
you appear
i was scared shitless with rick rubin
rick rubin is at when you first meet him
is intimidatingly calm but as you get to
know him a bit you realize that
his the kindness and the generosity that
you sense is real
um
but yeah i would never in a million
years uh have guessed that you get
anxious in conversation can i just make
another quick comment
this may come off entertaining to you
andrew maybe you've already gotten the
same
um but
having mentioned vladimir putin vladimir
zelonsky
uh
gelaine maxwell
there's a natural
question
how does lex
have access to these people
who does he work for
like how does he
who works for him for who works for him
right what does he have on others
this i'm actually i asked my i when i
look in the mirror
uh just somebody who kind of enjoys
conspiracy theories
i want to ask the same question like
well i usually ask in the following way
like how the [ __ ] am i so lucky like who
am i being in my robot being controlled
by somebody else or like
how is this how is this my life right
now what is happening it really does
feel like a simulation so let me just
speak
to several things first of all
i have no boss
i know i know of nor am i controlled
by any intelligence agencies of any
nation we're going to get you a dog lex
that i could talk to
i'm scared of getting a dog because i
would fall in love so deeply i think
that uh
next time i'm ringing on puppy
i'm just gonna bring a puppy i'm gonna
leave it here
man and then uh you'll never see me
again i mean i love dogs so much but the
uh i was also surprised and maybe
um i i have never
talked to an intelligence agency
which is very interesting to me like i i
i that you're aware of
because they're very good at
communicating right but i've been very
suspicious on this exact point that's
the downside of kind of
being an introvert having anxiety about
social interaction but then having so
much love thrown your way because
connect over podcast podcasts have a
powerful way of connecting people so
people come with you with love yeah that
i really love that i appreciate but i
wonder
like exactly this question like uh
like why is this person with a russian
accent talking to me and show showing me
so much love well because it's sorry to
interrupt you again but um it's what we
do um
and it's a sign of interest by the way
to sometimes sometimes yeah i have a
colleague at stanford and she said you
know interruption
75 percent of this time is a sign of
real interest in what the person is
saying if nothing else uh well
you're very lovable
well that that but i mean i learned
about uh hedgehog and the fog from you
yeah you know when i learned you know
you're very lovable people love you
because you're lovable i love love okay
so 100
and it's i mean especially here in
austin texas people are so so amazing i
go just hugs and just i i love people
but do you want a family are you
eventually 100 i mean you're i take what
you said as a challenge
uh in terms of uh having a family with
kids
and they do jiu jitsu and obviously
defeat you and and make you
um
miserable for your failures as a father
because you couldn't uh
but you're gonna be a great dad build up
an army of good jiu jitsu people but yes
i would love a family i would love to
have uh children but i just want to
finish that point because i'm nervous
about it i'm nervous about the way
people perceive what you're seeing is a
forrest gump type character like
who i am
i seem to be and this is how like the
world seems to work is you just try you
try to be yourself like you try to find
yourself
that's maybe the better way to say it
and just
be that
be kind to people
work your ass off
and
say f you to anybody that wants to
control you or to tell you what to do
just be free and then put love out there
in the world and doors open this karma
thing seems to work
uh some like how the hell did how the
hell am i friends with you now
how the hell did i get a chance to eat
barbecue with rick rubin right like
you guys had a barbecue had barbecue uh
he uh right of course he's from new york
any new yorker
that i know has very high standards for
food because bad restaurants don't last
long in new york and barbecue collins is
oh yeah oh yeah texas barbecue well you
know i would also add that you
whether or not you realized or not you
took tremendous risk i mean we come from
the same original community which is
academic science right and
to be at mit and to start posting
lectures online is risky right to
you know i was third or fourth man in on
in terms of podcasting as an academic
because
you had gone on rogan many times david
sinclair gone on there you know the
the especially before the the pandemic
you just didn't see many academics and
scientists talking in a public-facing
way
so you took tremendous risk right you
took tremendous risk always wearing that
jacket and tie right
the only time i haven't seen you in that
truly is when we rolled jiu jitsu which
is and i hear i'm being generous to
myself saying i rolled you just
basically you choked me out in front of
me that was really really it was uh it
was uh
it was great fun and i i i thank you for
doing that to have a beginner's mind
it's a beautiful thing i have admittedly
i have not been taking the classes but
i'm going to i truly am um especially
there's a small chance i might find
myself in austin a bit more often in the
in the near future but the
well if you're out in san francisco you
train with mark zuckerberg he just
started so oh yeah you guys get
interesting
sure
i mean he's actually uh i mean people
listen to an episode perhaps he's a
fascinating human being listen to it
that's great
you took tremendous risk as an academic
to do what you did so i do believe that
when one takes intelligent risk because
you can die you can crash your career
you can do all sorts of um
self-destructive or
destructive things when taking risks you
took risks and and they paid off right
and you take different risks at
different stages but i
i don't throw around the word admiration
lightly i mean i admire that you were in
this classroom and mit like i'm gonna
film this and put it online uh you one
of your early interviews is with ido
portal who's very hard to get to
i've communicated with edo a few times i
should definitely talk to him i can't
wait to talk to him i'm dying to talk to
him i was supposed to do some um course
teaching with him uh right before the
pandemic head and then it got canceled
because he couldn't travel but getting
to him is exceedingly challenging so you
do have this incredible ability to get
to people
and for them to trust you and know you
and i think it's through your
authenticity and i think it's the fact
that you're willing to go places where
people haven't been before you know this
is what what's the saying about pioneers
how do you spot the pioneers they're the
people with the arrows in their backs
you know so that that's the
you know yeah and and that's actually a
quote that i lifted from terry signowski
who's a uh there you go you know
sources again um terry's uh you should
talk to terry he's a um
uh computational neuroscientist down at
the salk institute uh howard hughes
investigator etc but so you know
taking risks that other people have not
taken
is
that's a real thing
and to do it with uh integrity and rigor
that's a real thing and so yeah i'm
complimenting you and i hope it i hope
it lands and lands deeply but i also
hope that people will hear that and
understand that
it's one thing to to
do what other people are already doing
boldly it's a whole other thing to
launch an entire art form or venue and
you did that
and uh you didn't write a book hopefully
you will someday but you didn't go write
a book a lot of academics have written
books
you went online
jordan peterson another controversial
character he did it too all those
lectures that he filmed and then it's
led to this other thing so um
you know
there's karma and then there's also
having the spine to just
put it all on the line and do something
for which there is no prior example
to hold on to
while you go through those headwinds the
really fascinating thing actually a lot
of people tell me about you andrew
huberman
like
the reach of a podcast is really
fascinating it's not the
it's not the numbers of people listen i
don't know if that's important at all
is what's important is like the depth of
connection you have with certain people
it really moves them like a great and
like they really get you
so there's a lot of big andrew huberman
fans that really get you it's not just
the science it's the stuff between the
lines it's costello it's the whole
picture of a scientist that finds beauty
and biology and reveals it and they love
you for it you know um
because it was on television at the time
i followed that amanda knox story pretty
carefully um and i don't watch
television but whenever i would travel
if there was a tv in the airplane i
would find myself um getting wrapped
into things like locked up abroad you
know like and these things where would
you make you terrified to travel
anywhere let alone commit a crime
overseas um you know the the scenes of
some of these prisons are so dramatic
and you know i mean her case got a ton
of interest and then i you know she went
and then was a student at the university
of washington um and has talked quite
openly about you know how she was
treated and how people assumed guilt and
you know and eventually you know she was
exonerated and you know we can only go
by what we know what the law determined
but you know these are people that
the world is fascinated by
i would i'm guessing about a third of
people have already decided this person
is despicable why would you ever give
them an audience about a third of people
i think are open
to or at least interested in learning
more about them
and then i think the the remaining third
kind of the third that
the category that i put myself in which
is what can i learn about people
and myself
even in my revulsion
right what can i learn
yeah what can i learn about myself from
listening to this conversation with
somebody that i
that i like to think i'm not talking
about amanda here i'm talking about the
other people you're talking about that i
i don't i can't relate to right talk
hearing conversations
with and about people that you cannot
relate to is informative otherwise your
whole mind literally becomes insular
right well there's an interesting thing
i also had to
um ever since the war in ukraine broke
up
one of the questions i was asking myself
and this is not to be dramatic it's just
a very simple honest question
that i think a lot of journalists that
operate in the war zone
or documenting filmmakers that have
recently got a chance to meet
have to be honest with themselves
are you willing to put at risk
your life for
things you do
what are you willing to die for yeah
what are you willing to die for it
sounds very dramatic
but
whenever risk goes up
i mean i don't know you you ask that if
you want to take out a trip out to space
on a commercial space flight
you have to are you willing are you
willing to die for this for this journey
now the odds that are really small i
just watched apollo 13 again yeah great
movie yeah great i'm not going to space
i'm not going to space
i'm afraid of heights no i'm not afraid
of heights i'm i just it feels like a
feels like a terrible place to die
yeah
well first of all death anywhere is not
great yeah although you know i have um a
song
teed up in my phone if my if the plane
starts to go down yeah i'm gonna spend
the last few it's a rare song nobody
knows it's a song off a b track of my
favorite band which is rances this one
called the sentence and nobody nobody
and i love it and i listen to it almost
every day um right answer this the
sentence it's called the the band is
called rancid the famous band yeah
relatively love those guys love their
music um and the song is the sentence
you can only find it on like a b-sider
outtake and it's if you don't know
how to decipher tim armstrong's voice
then you probably won't understand the
lyrics but um
because it's sung very very fast but if
the plane ever goes anytime there's
turbulence i put that thing and i put
the headphones in i'm like well you know
if it's time it's time i'm going to go
out like this i don't want to drift off
into the galaxy just slowly asphyxiating
and freezing to death that sounds
horrible
just like i wouldn't want to drown or
put on a plane is okay well on a plane i
mean like if the thing starts going down
and there's truly nothing you can do you
might as well at least listen to your
favorite song yeah true true i'll
probably go with the pixies where's my
mind like from fight club
and just the calmness just sit back like
uh the musicians playing at the titanic
i didn't know you were a pixies fan i'm
gonna have to not not so much a pixies
fan actually i i should say that i just
that was the where's my mind it was the
chosen song for fight club
at the end when the buildings are coming
down or something like that so that the
the there's certain songs that just fit
just right
for the collapse of human civilization
and you you're calmly
appreciating
like
that that's just it this is how absurd
this life is at any moment it can end
and this is it this is uh
i love how we both have uh death and
demise yeah um soundtracks it's just a
question
when you're an academic doesn't come up
often
right that's all that's that's yeah
there are some academics that are
bold and brave it's it's not a phenotype
being bold and brave in the physical
world is not a common phenotype of
academics i mean the great neurologist
one of my i don't have any heroes but
oliver sacks is a true hero i mean
people think of him as a writer but he
was foremost a neurologist and he took
tremendous
pushback from the neurology community
for doing his books and his articles
he has a great biography called on the
move there's a wonderful documentary
that just came out about him he died in
2015. i'm actually um
kind of a collector of his things um but
he tremendous but he was accused of
horrible things
until the movie awakenings came out with
de niro and robin williams amazing movie
by the way people don't yeah they seem
to not say great things about the movie
i love them it was amazing and it was
only once he became famous from that
movie
that his act more academic work started
to receive any kind of attention and he
was invited back to colombia and nyu
yeah the new york neuroscience mafia is
a real thing um and yes you know who you
are and some of them are actually coming
on the broadcast um they they they are
you know uh i think we talked offline
about this we should start a mafia to
bat to fight off whatever is going on in
the east coast although i'm still in
rmit so i don't know how that works but
well it's different than new york yeah
so i have tremendous respect for science
done in new york don't get me wrong they
are excellent scientists it's it's just
a very different culture than on the
west coast um and the personalities the
the personality tremendous respect for
the mob
well
and the personalities are are a bit more
um
grandiose however because of some of the
shift in
science culture in the last few years
things around scandals and things of
that sort
they've been forced to tamp down some of
their personality or at least their
outspoken personality and i actually
think it's revealed something really
important and useful in science which is
you know it used to be the case you
could really inject your personality
into what you do you know
richard feynman's a good example
if he did
today what he did then bongo drumming on
the roof of caltech naked um working out
theorems in um strip clubs and things of
that he would have lost his job in
moments right so that kind of behavior
isn't celebrated anymore it's actually
punished um and i'm only half kidding
about this new york neuroscience mafia
but because i now exist in multiple
realms i can say these sorts of things
and i again admiration and respect but i
will say that i think it's important
that people in science or their and kids
that are curious about science
understand that
you can have any personality provided
that you're ethical and respectful in
science and do well right they're
true bench scientists that just want to
be at the bench there are people that
just want to be in their office they're
people that um really enjoy public
speaking and there are people that love
meetings there are people that hate
crowds and so there's a place for
everybody truly a place for everybody in
science
i would like to be able to shine light
on the fact that there are you can have
a shy personality an outgoing
personality and you can all of those can
be have excellent careers in science but
you have to find the community in place
that's right for you one reason i like
stanford is that stanford is very much
about the future we have nobel prize
winners we have field medal winners and
all that stuff and their names are on
walls and we acknowledge their great
works but most of what you hear about in
the halls of stanford is about what's
happening now and what could happen next
it's really about the future whereas
when i've spent time at other
institutions not to be named
you hear that but there's a lot of kind
of recycling and regurgitation of how
wonderful people are based on things
they did previously
and the students at stanford because of
silicon valley sure they have respect
for nobel prizes they're delighted to be
learning from and surrounded by all
these great minds but they're mostly
interested in what they're gonna create
and so i kind of uh not kind of i really
like the shift toward possibility as
opposed to things that are steeped in
tradition you know i've never been to
high table dinner at oxford i'm sure
it's a wonderful experience
i'm also not sure what purpose it serves
for the world
but i've never been and so i don't know
what the conversations are and so maybe
i'm you know
speaking out of line here and then now
i'm definitely not getting invited now
you're you're definitely getting invited
but yeah i'm with you the the cultures
pick the right ones for you that's why i
like mit this the spirit of it
to me
it's not about the past or the future
it's about just
tinkering and having fun building cool
stuff like the big ambitious projects
it's there
i mean maybe more on the biology and the
health side but like the engineering
side it doesn't matter if this has any
impact let us build the coolest thing
the world has ever built
there uh whenever i'm in kendall square
i've seen uh the they have those
buildings there that actually tilt
toward the ground these are these uh the
architecture of mit is also really
impressive yeah this uh he pulled up uh
sergey just pulled up yama's tweet i'm
inspired by curiosity that is what
drives me so let us expand the scope and
scale of consciousness so that we may
aspire to understand the universe
there's like three tweets in one but
curiosity yeah yeah curiosity for its
own
sake what's that saying um
i think dorothy parker said uh
the cure for boredom is curiosity
there's no cure for curiosity
and you need to celebrate so let me just
briefly mention
to my lovely
friends at mit
to celebrate different
weirdness to celebrate the weird
characters i've um
i sometimes get loving
pressure
from
my lovely friends at mit
to
tone down the weirdness a bit
really even from mit
i'm very fortunate to have a lot of
leverage
to where i have
completely resist the pressure
but i i'm very sure that there's young
faculty
that with that subtle pressure
would
um
dissolve them into a puddle of tears
not no no they're from boston excuse me
that's right they're tougher than that
that's right but it's a slight nudging
towards conformity that i think
ultimately destroys
um
or at least lessens
the
uh the power of the kind of science that
you can do when you encourage
diversity diversity in all of its forms
including the weirdness of ideas the out
of the box thinkers including the
flamboyant behavior online
uh
how you choose to educate how you choose
to inspire you know people talk about
freedom of speech but it's not just like
freedom of speech to say
controversial things it's also freedom
of speech to be weird like if you're for
some reason fascinated in
uh like you look at elon musk he talks
about sex a lot let the guy put sex
memes up who cares like i mean i feel
like
elon can do basically whatever he wants
right there's no pressure but there's a
bunch of elons in the academic world
there's a bunch of uh
no actually sorry let me backtrack
because
the man deserves props right he's
unparalleled he's he's a ceo of major
companies you better believe there's
pressure
to behave more like a ceo as opposed to
a giggling
schoolboy who's posting memes throughout
the night
but that is him
and that freedom that's what freedom
looks like i talked to a lot of ceos
and a lot of them
feel like uh caged birds
who have long ago forgotten how to sing
quite honestly like they they there's
like shareholders and they come up with
excuses for themselves here's why i have
to be this way you have to understand
so on there's pr there's marketing
people there's lawyers there's all that
kind of stuff
but
the final result is the authenticity
suffocated
the the beautiful weirdness of a ceo of
a leader of a creator of a scientist all
that that's all
uh
that's all gone well steve steve jobs
wouldn't have
kept his job in
acting the way he did in his 20s and 30s
in today's climate but he probably would
have updated his uh
his protocols so a little bit but maybe
yeah screaming at employees i mean these
are these are anecdotes right i call
them anecdata because people treat them
as data but they're they're really just
anecdotes we don't know i wasn't there
um
but you know i i like the idea of
authenticity without over sharing
right you're very authentic but there
are aspects to your life that i'm aware
of that your audiences will never be
aware of and there are aspects of your
life that i'll never be aware of and so
you're still authentic but yeah which
way which ones are you aware
people are going to wonder like what
what is you think i'm going to trip sex
dungeon what is this no no no
but interesting but interesting choice
of examples um
no but i think that um
you know people lose
lose careers on the basis of
the movement of their thumbs right i
mean the chair of psychiatry at columbia
recently lost his position based on a
response to a tweet people can look that
up this is one of the most famous
psychiatry departments in the world and
he put something out there that was very
insensitive uh frankly and um everyone
that i
talked to about it was like gosh that
was very
very insensitive not thoughtful at all
and and he lost his job right or at
least had to step down i don't know the
specifics so um you know
i think i read someplace that more than
half of the uh job loss due to online
behavior is because people were trying
to be funny
right i mean
not everyone can pull off what tim
dillon
oh and by the way congratulations i
heard that you and just got married yeah
no no we didn't just get married yeah he
proposed let's go got it got it got it
and i said um yes right so some people
can get away oh yeah thank you thank you
sergey has that
likes one of those is mine
uh so for people who are not aware one
of the days in april
tweeted that tim dillon asked me to get
married and i said yes i think tim
uh said uh the wedding will be on sixth
street in austin bring all of your
weapons which of course is the totally
inappropriate this is
this is i i was he's
i was like uh pg funny and he's goes
rated r uh funny right away
but that said
i mean if there's anyone
i i would like to get married with this
it's that guy and he would do it in
austin and
it would
it would it would be epic it would be
like the uh the wedding from november
rain
um
one of them
mr mrs oh wow oh mr mister i apologize
well yeah and you broke and you broke
tradition with the with the jacket color
so it sounds to me that you are a free
speech absolutist
i think freedom is really important and
that includes
letting people who are hateful letting
people who are controversial
have a voice on platforms but
it becomes
i'm not sure what exactly to think
because um
i also treasure
the quiet voices in the back of the room
and sometimes the [ __ ]
um silence those voices meaning by being
loud and obnoxious and so on it pushes
away the thoughtful people so i'm also a
fan of creating communities
like you should be able to
let people kind of
build a community that's positive that's
loving
or that's
constantly trolling or that's uh
super hateful all those communities
should have a place in the world but
like
the thing i've noticed is that
hate can destroy
a community full of hate and destroy a
community full of love easier than a
community full of love can overtake one
with hate and so you have to kind of
i don't know exactly how but create
digital mechanisms
that
discourage the collision of these
communities they should all have a
platform an ability to speak at a large
audience but i just
you have to be careful to protect that
like little flame of
um
of connection that people have that's
good the goodness it sounds like i mean
the um yeah i think you you you know in
any great city like new york which i
love by the way um
you want to have a symphony and an opera
house and you want some punk rock shows
happening on the lower east side you you
want all of that
you just don't necessarily want them to
overlap
in terms of social media you know and
then podcast and engagement one thing
that i decided very early on is was to
encourage comments and feedback etc but
i have in my mind what i call classroom
rules
you've taught in the university and then
you teach in the university and they're
certain you establish a certain
etiquette within the classroom of the
kinds of questions that you'll tolerate
right so there's always the student
that's going to ask a question which is
basically a 10-minute monologue about
their experience that really isn't a
question that pertains to a lot of
people so you you um politely discourage
that kind of question and you encourage
the kinds of questions that are likely
to be in the minds of many other
students it's just more efficient that
way or not politely which is more
you know i try and respond to comments
and i try and respond but also you know
there's this also this really
interesting question now if uh you block
people or restrict people people think
that you're somehow afraid of the
information that they're posting but
that's often not the case i'm not in the
habit of blocking or restricting too
many people occasionally we've had to do
it only because of how other people are
being treated in the comments section
what i can take and what i think other
people deserve to take are two
completely different things david
goggins right who we both know well um i
don't know if he still does this but a
few years ago he posted something like
if people ask him when do you sleep
he would just block them yeah because it
wasn't consistent with what he was
trying to say of course he sleeps but
it's you know he's trying to get a
particular message out i think people
should just understand that everybody's
page is their own
to
moderate right just like in a classroom
there are certain rules of course of
institution but then you establish the
etiquette within the context of the kind
of class you know a class about
personality psychology or the psychology
of love you're gonna have a very
different range of of conversations than
uh you know a class on um you know
membrane physiology
so i i think um
social media is a great place for
conversation but it's not necessarily a
great place for every kind of
conversation yeah and i also just say
the people that do get blocked
i never
this is something i do very deliberately
blocked or ignored
i never think poorly of them i actually
explicitly
think
if if there's somebody that's like
saying hateful things about me whatever
i always think positive thoughts it's
not some kind of weird guru thing but
just actually found that as a hack i i
think well of them and that allows me to
never think of them again
like i send them my love and like i
think this is a like fascinating human
being with a fascinating story i would
love to have time to actually learn
about their story but there's not enough
time in the world and i just think well
of them and then and move on and enjoy a
delicious meal with people that are
close to me and i love and so on and
just
and move on and never adding to the
negativity of like just even in the
privacy of my own mind thinking a
hateful thought towards them it serves
no purpose whatsoever yeah i love that
about you and i know that what you just
said to be true one of the i think more
um
toxic things in life is what's called um
you know evacuative projection when
people feel something and they try and
evacuate it and project it onto somebody
else projection is fascinating right
what you essentially just said is that
you don't accept projections
in in fact you transmute them to put in
the language of the buddhists you know
you transmute it into positivity and in
that way you you you truly neutralize it
um
and transmute it
i think that
if people were better understood when
they were experiencing or observing
evacuative projection
um
the world would be a much healthier and
happier place but it requires a certain
a stable internal rudder and um you know
when we're tired or sick or angry you
know we are hungry excessively hungry um
all of us are less less good at it i've
been positively struck by the nature of
most of the
interactions not just feedback but my
favorite thing
as an educator in the classroom but also
on social media my absolute favorite
thing is when the comments about other
people's comments
are positively reinforcing so you see
people having conversations within the
comments yeah and you realize this is
like if you as an educator again you
know you it's fun to teach and it's fun
to talk to the students but the real
pleasure is in walking by a small group
of students on campus and hearing them
talking about the material
that's that just fills me with joy
and
because what it means is that the ideas
are reverberating in their nervous
systems and will eventually wick out to
others
so it's not just about feedback it's
about a venue for for parsing
information so you actually posted that
we're going to talk on instagram and i
collected a bunch of the questions which
reminds me of i have to um
mention mike jones and a question he
asked but also a gift he gave quite a
while ago if it's okay but first uh
quick bathroom break yes
we're looking at an instagram page of uh
mike jones knife and tool you should
check it out
he get he uh andrew gave me a gift from
him
that
is a badass
a butcher knife
yours is the earth da da da is from if
by russia kipling yeah the story of this
knife is kind of interesting perhaps to
people where it was i was coming out
here to austin to meet with lex and it
was his birthday i want to get him a
gift but i didn't know what to get him
and i contacted this guy mike jones that
i learned about through joe rogan
because the first remember in the old
days of joe rogan when you go on the
episode afterwards you'd take a picture
with an object so it's like elon with a
flamethrower or people would have the
axe i picked up this um bushwhacker
hatchet thing nice and i was like i love
this thing and and joe said oh yeah you
should check out mike jones's work he
does these beautiful knives and so
then i
heard your episode with joe and you
recited a poem at the end it was right
after your grandmother died
and
there's a line in that poem from from if
that um mike engraved on that knife for
you so he makes these by by hand i love
scratch there's the old days
[Laughter]
before the podcast and first appearance
that was the first time on there and um
it was a lot of fun um in the old in the
old studio in los angeles and um
yeah mike makes these beautiful knives
and i have this in i just have a great
admiration for crafts people yeah so
yeah do you use it do you cut your your
one meal a day steaks i feel
are you taking it with you on your
travels exactly
i actually uh used to keep it on the
table but i thought it really
intimidates guests a little bit
but like you put it on their side yeah
right it's like oops it's it's trust
right
what's what's the story i mean yeah so
but it's because it's not
it's it's uh quite badass if i may say
so the craftsmanship is obvious but also
it is a knife
it's got some like dexter-like qualities
to it yeah it looks like it's designed
to to cleave through a limb if i had
like a family or something where people
there's nothing about this place that
softens your
kind of
sense that this my
person might not murder me
let's put it differently uh this place
could use a woman's
touch that's one way to put it if it's
okay let me because it is it is a poem i
um
go go to often actually
uh you mentioned reciting some lyrics
and i'm actually gonna go back to that
at some point to get get a few songs
that touch you
um
but this is one of the things i i go to
often i i
i'll read it to remind myself it's uh
advice from
from father to son and it's a kind of
mantra that it's just nice to live by so
if it's killing me just use this
opportunity one more time read if by
rojak kipling
if you can keep your head when all about
your losing theirs and blaming it on you
if you can trust yourself when all men
doubt you but make allowance for their
doubting too
if you can wait to not be tired by
waiting or being lied about don't deal
in lies
or being hated don't give way to hating
and yet don't look too good nor talk too
wise
if you can dream and not make dreams
your master if you can think and not
make thoughts your aim if you can meet
with triumph and disaster and treat
those two imposters just the same
if you can bear to hear the truth you've
spoken twisted by nays to make a trap
for fools or watch the things you gave
your life to broken
and stoop and build them up with worn
out tools if you can make one heap of
all your winnings and risk it all
on one turn of pitch and toss
and lose and start again at your
beginnings
and never breathe a word about your loss
if you can force your heart to nerve and
sin you to serve your turn long after
they're gone
and so hold on when there's nothing in
you except the will which says to them
hold on
if you can talk with crowds and keep
your virtue i like this one and walk
with kings nor lose the common touch
if neither foes and their loving friends
can hurt you if all men count with you
but none too much
if you can fill the unforgiving minute
with 60 seconds worth of distance run
yours is the earth and everything that's
in it
and which is more you'll be a man my son
thank you andrew thank you thank you
mike for the knife it's a
i don't know it's it's it's beautiful
and engraved in it
yeah it's yours yours is the earth and
everything that's in it
we toiled over what to engrave and then
finally i just said mike just
pick something that speaks to you you're
the craftsman and so he selected that
there's certain ways to pull yourself in
that book actually uh karl dasser
daisarath he wrote the book projections
one of my favorite first of all just as
you said
incredible writer
just amazing just i mean um
if you wrote fiction if you wrote those
kinds of things i'm curious to see where
he goes with his writing it's very
interesting i think that book took him
10 years to write
which is vindication for me and for you
because we're both supposed to write
books and we haven't done it
yeah i mean you know in some sense
you're
um first book will have
you know decades in it right even if you
just take uh half a year to write it
it's like the first book like the first
album for a musician i mean it's a life
it's a journey it's a it's a it's ever
but he he uses uh
poems and quotes in there really well
it's a beautiful book it's a dreamy book
i think when people hear
that it's a book about neuroscience they
think they're going to get a textbook or
a protocols book or something it's
nothing like that but it really is a
deep dive into the mind of the
psychiatrist and the researcher and so
much feeling and compassion i love that
you love poetry i mean i didn't know
that until i saw you on rogan read if
um and
i'm not a
very uh rabid consumer of poetry but i
i'm a big wendell berry fan
um
and i try and read
a poem once every few days
also i think it if is a tough act to
follow oh yeah yeah oh yeah i mean
that's
the richness and the i mean like you
said ev every
third line in there is something that
you would you know you'd
consider your life well lived if you if
you said that
right what about the uh preparation for
the solo podcast you said you listen to
certain songs you know you sing or
recite the lyrics certain songs is there
ones that kind of come to mind that are
interesting
um
yeah i've always been very lyrics driven
and i don't understand music i've talked
to rick about this i think i've talked
to you about this a little bit i don't
really understand
i mean i can hear
music and like it but i don't really
understand the structure of it but
lyrics make a lot of sense does it touch
your soul music or is it the lyrics it's
the lyrics it's not the instrumentals so
i'm a huge joe strummer fan and i'm
gonna lose punk points for saying this
but i'm not a clash fan oh okay so he
obviously is best known for the clash
most clash song start off great and then
after about 30 seconds in at least in my
mind just kind of disintegrated into a
bunch of mush whereas um
joe strummer and the mescaleros which is
what he did as an adult
as a you know later and some of his solo
work he actually rick produced some work
that he did with johnny cash you know
rick pulled johnny cash out of
essentially out of retirement and had
him do his albums before he he died and
um so anything that strummer did there's
a there's a favorite song of mine by
strummer it's called burning lights
um you can find it there is an album now
where you can find it or tennessee rain
or some of these things that he did
which are a little bit more folky so not
really punk so i love that song um a
bunch of songs by rancid that i love you
know
you know and then if i listen to
instrumentals i do
um
i'll listen to classical piano some
dreams are made for children but it's
not going to sound good as a poem they
can play this people can play the song
okay yeah so i'll
i mean because it has to be something
joe's voice is what makes the song got
it um joe's voice is what makes the song
but yeah that song burning lights from i
married uh i hired a contract killer or
no the licks are pretty good they're
pretty good i mean joe is an amazing
writer right i'm you know i'm also a big
bob dylan fan um glenn gould for
classical piano he was at asperger's you
know and um and actually i think you can
hear him grunting he had a tourette's
like tick
um and i learned about glenn gould from
oliver sacks
so i'll listen to any number of things
it depends on my mood if i'm feeling a
little more tired and i need to be amped
up i'll listen to something that's a
little louder and faster if i'm feeling
kind of keyed up and i need to bring the
cadence down a little bit um
then i'll listen to something a little
mellower poppier i
i love bands like um
yeah i'm a big fan of this um british
pop band called james there's like 20
bands named james but this one you know
and again i lose punk points for saying
that but they're amazing uh and best of
luck you've accumulated enough points
where you can afford to view
to lose a few yeah um but in any case uh
yeah music and poetry are they're
they're the they're the subconscious
right i mean if you think about a bob
dylan song or a really good strummer
song or a poem that the the words don't
mean anything when read linearly but
they make you feel something they're
tapping into the subconscious
that's really what they're doing they're
pulling on neural threads of emotion
based on either timbre or cadence or
something that's independent of the word
structure
and that to me is the beauty of music
and poetry i often say johnny cash's
version hurt that i say would be my
favorite
song ever he did a nine inch nail song
he did he caught i think rick produced
that he pretty sure he yes he produced
it i mean he did like the rick produced
the he pulled johnny cash out
from a dark place to produce something
that um
i mean when you look back is one of the
great things
ever in music which are these
like uh haunting covers of certain songs
and originals
johnny cash and joe strummer did
a version of redemption song together
that is uh that rick produced
which is um on loop in my house
sometimes you know for hours and hours
that song is fascinating bob marley's
song
sung by johnny cash and joe strummer you
know sometimes i think what it would be
to be a fly on the wall when these guys
were doing this these songs of freedom
there's certain songs where you're like
it um
elicit
an emotion
that's unlike anything else i mean i was
i was trying to figure that out with
with rick too like there's certain songs
that make you want to pull up over to
the side of the road and just
weep or just uh get inspired to just get
[ __ ] done or all those kinds of things
or remember your
family the people you've lost all that
kind of stuff me hurt
i hurt myself today to see if i still
feel there's certain songs that um i've
loved so much that i actually won't play
them
during a relationship until the
relationship passes a certain
duration because you if you start
sharing in those experiences with
somebody in the room and it starts to
become associated with the relationship
you braiding it in with the dopamine of
of love and that relationship ends the
song is forever tainted there are
certain songs that i will never play in
the company of anybody else yeah they're
mine
i just it's too risky
to uh to give those up um and uh you
know
and i think that um there's like levels
they're levels right
exactly
we'll leave it at that
yeah and uh the interesting thing about
this kind of preparing for the solo
episode
uh just interacting with rick about that
process of preparation and
because you mentioned uh
with interviews
by the way so are you doing solo solo
are you the only one in the room or no
i've well it used to be rob my producer
who um i should say you know
he's really the person behind the the
podcast i mean we're first of all we're
equal partners you're just a pretty face
uh we're just um and i'm aging man not
to not so i love him i actually really
hate it i like i like aging it's weird a
lot of people like d friends with david
sinclair and it's all about not aging i
i'm i don't want to live past 90 95. i'm
just trying to get as much done as i can
in this short life and do it right and
with integrity and heart and accuracy
you know um and you like the stages oh
yeah if you read erickson's stages of
development you realize that every
stage of life is is a set of neural
circuits trying to resolve a problem and
um and if you're going to try and avoid
that progression sure
you might live longer but um you know
it's sort of like saying like do you
want to go win the
uh high school jiu jitsu championship no
you graduated high school a long time
ago right so i actually look forward to
the future
um even if it means that i'm starting to
shift i think that uh my biology will
shift you know i'll fight that i try and
take good care of myself but um i don't
want to get sick i don't want to suffer
who does but i i'm embracing this whole
developmental arc i mean
we don't
we're not children and then adults our
entire life is one long developmental
arc
and if you fail to embrace that you fail
to extract the richness of of what it is
to be a human being so um
in any event for the um
i record uh
rob is in the room
i'll sometimes stop and ask him for
feedback if i feel like something's not
landing right so he gives if it's clear
he'll let me know if it's not clear
he'll let me know excuse me and then you
know costello used to be in the room the
early days of the podcast which weren't
that long ago
he's snoring at my feet and
farting and smelling up the room and
we're all just kind of like gasping for
air he's a bulldog that's what they do
with him gone it it changed you know
that the whole thing changed there will
be another dog soon um
and as you know i uh i've been moving
through that grief process but having
him there gave me a levity
that um i miss but in my mind he's still
there yeah he's still there yeah he's
still there so uh and you know in time
there'll be another dog and and who
knows you know maybe there'll be a dog
and a couple infants running around but
that would be more distracting so um
but
it's there's no podcast that exists
just because of the podcaster this is
true for joe it's true for your podcast
for me that there's it's not just a
staff of people that post stuff that's
just the top level contour there's the
constant feedback and iteration of what
you want it to become
and
trying to hold on to something that's
essential along the way because
everything has to evolve but you can't
lose the the essence of something
anytime a company or brand or a
course or a
scientist has done that it just ends up
terrible it just is a you know it
becomes like a cenatar version of itself
so to rick is very
the the power of the people in the room
is great
to and to inspire and to destroy so you
have to be extremely careful
with the selection of people that are in
the room to me i never really thought of
it that way i
i i thought only only positive things
could happen oh by adding people by
adding people oh i think if there were
in an audience in the room well you know
what someday i'd love to do a live
podcast with you um we're just i saw you
doing like a a couple of live things
which is great that you're paving the
way there to well we did try things i
went up to university of british
columbia um
uh and did a
a lecture on a on a college campus and
one of the more gratifying things that
happens this guy this kid in his early
20s i think stood up and said you know
i've never been on a college campus i
didn't think i could go on to a college
campus and that i still rings on my mind
whoever you are out there that meant so
much to me because i was like yes there
was something about that to me i was
like
okay this it made sense to come all the
way up here and do this in person
because you can get out to a lot more
people online
public speaking events it's not like
it's that lucrative or anything i mean
unless you're whatever you're a famous
celebrity or politician or something i'm
sure there are people that do well with
it but that's not what it's about for us
it's really about being able to connect
with people in a different venue and for
interactions like that uh i don't know
how many of them we will do um
but i'm curious to see how it goes but
i'd love to do a
podcast with you is it energizing my my
fear
is the the fear of the introvert
is that
i don't know if i can handle so much
love and
fascinating people all around
it's like i don't know
well we'll invite a few haters too
well yes
but i love the haters too but
i don't know it makes me nervous because
jordan peterson is currently on tour i
got a chance to hang out with him right
he does he does um
a lot of live speaking yeah he does like
he's not on tour where he does like
every other day
and
but he doesn't have any small kids at
home anymore so no do that so yeah you
should do it before you're so exhausting
i mean yeah
i'm just speaking from an athlete
perspective like
if you're mick jagger with the rolling
stones it it's just
physically
i mean you have to speak potentially for
two hours
then off stage
like hanging out with people it's a lot
it's a lot of hours it's a lot of hours
to stay focused to
to keep finding your place of like
calmness and excitement well and you're
staying in hotels your circadian rhythm
is disrupted you're not getting your
like cold and sauna and your workout
every day your food isn't optimal um i
think done in patches i could enjoy it
um because it's fun to meet people from
different places i'm doing a public
lecture in copenhagen for the lundbeck
foundation in june june 3rd and that one
is particularly gratifying for me
because the lundbeck foundation is an
academic foundation so the fact that and
then so when they invited i asked you
know do you want me to talk about what
my lab does or do you want me to talk
about this stuff on the podcast they're
like no no not your laugh
we want to hear about this like health
stuff and the stuff that we cover on the
podcast so that was amusing to me and
tells me that um
you know things are changing now i think
2020 and 2021 revealed a lot of things
about
people to ourselves but one thing that
it made very clear is that there's an
enormous appetite
for tools
for mental and physical health but also
understanding about science and how
science is done so thanks to you again
i'm not saying this to flatter you it's
true gratitude there is now a a runway
for scientists to talk to people i mean
you had that i always forget this guy's
name the virus guy from colombia uh
vincent wrecking yellow yeah amazing
right i mean forgetting the controversy
around all the stuff of 20 20 21 i mean
he is an encyclopedia of all things
virology yeah people should listen to
his podcast this week in virology he's
also an incredible lecturer and educator
it's uh
it's fascinating it's fascinating yeah
when people take again that leap of
putting all that education online
that's non-controversial at all it's
it's like everybody there
people should go listen to him for the
most part in in terms of
at his best at least there's no politics
in it there's there's there's none other
no he's a virus jockey he likes playing
around with
bacteria and viruses and but that said
we all molecular biology we all say
stuff carelessly all the time so he he
gets in a bit of trouble on some of the
things he said about like
dismissing lab leak theory like
there's no way he dismisses that yeah
but not he's not making like folks
uh there's a difference when you say
stuff
like off the cuff
and
when you say stuff that's like core to
your principles and you've thought about
it for a very long time are you're
talking for hour for hundreds of hours
and you can just say stuff you could
just say your opinions um
will smith uh slap i was wondering okay
wait how long have we been recording i
was wondering how long it was gonna take
us before someone talked about ukraine
no no will smith yeah i was wondering
whether or not we'd make it then i had
it planned yeah i was literally in the
back of my house i had it planned that
at the end if we didn't talk about the
will smith chris rock thing that i was
going to say
it's amazing this is the first
conversation to happen and uh in a long
time where
it wasn't mentioned oh no thank you
you're not pulling it up
here we go we don't need this here we go
it revealed some interesting things
about um
human beings impulse control and uh lack
thereof but um
you know
oh my goodness chris rock has a material
for the rest of his career yeah i think
he's he's not short on material but i do
see if i if i knew what i i wanted to
tweet if if i knew you're allowed to
just slap comedians my conversation with
tim dillon would have gone very
differently
people just being humans i
there's so much fascinating human nature
on display there
um it's also in terms of it coming it
becoming a topic that a lot of people
are talking about versus the war in
ukraine for example is also fascinating
to watch like just these kind of news
cycles moving through and i think if i
may i sorry to interrupt but um you know
anytime we observe something very limbic
very emotional
you know we
generally can empathize
somewhat
right uh we all know it's like to feel
angry we all know it's like to feel
ashamed we all know what it's like to
feel shocked
images of war
are
for most people very hard to relate to
we see it it's you know the these images
and they're very
traumatic and and challenging to look at
at times and yet most people have no
idea what it feels like to be shot at or
what it feels like to have your home
destroyed or what it feels like to be
um
an aggressor in that way so it's very so
i think that people naturally orient
towards things that feel familiar to
them even though the circumstances are
different and people also forget they
look at these celebrities
it's just like looking at criticism of
will smith you forget that
they're human too
that's that's one of the most surprising
things for me having done this
podcast and met celebrities and stuff
like that
they're human
they're all human and that's inspiring
to me like some of these great folks
that have won nobel prizes and built
some cool things they're just human like
the rest of us well and if you look at
actors and actresses i mean there's some
amazing ones right and who also do well
in the outside life but their careers
were built on
the
business of
pretending to be other people yeah and
that's got to distort
maybe positively but also
just
let's be honest what it is that the
neuroplasticity there the changes in the
areas of the brain that represent
personality have to be quite different
for somebody who pretends to be lots of
different personalities and gets paid
for it you're working the reward system
into the system of self-identity and
you know you have to imagine that that
can really
contort
somebody's neurology in ways that maybe
they are not as in maybe they are not in
touch with reality in the same way that
we are remember earlier we talked about
neurotic versus psychotic
you know they may be more borderline
in their kind of ground state than than
we think and so i'm actually impressed
anytime there's a celebrity who doesn't
have a messed up life yeah i'm like oh
wow you know finally somebody who's
managed to you know maintain a some
semblance at least from the outside of
normalcy so first of all i can empathize
with the actions that will smith did
right they're not
i think they're kind of sh not kind of
they're just shitty
you should probably talk privately
man-to-man
uh not because otherwise it's like a
dramatic display
it's like it's almost like you are a
fake act you're acting well they're all
these questions right i mean obviously
it was
aggressive at some level there's this
question of whether or not it was
impulsive i think most people feel yes
there's a question there was the
protective nature of it because he was
doing it to you know in it apparently to
in defense but then there's also the the
context
he lost touch with the context right um
whereas chris rock basically gets um
there there's the possible critique that
he went too far
that's going to be in the eye of the
beholder um but then and depending on
how you view comedy and jokes but then
there's also the fact that he took that
slap and then just snapped right back so
much so that people thought maybe it was
fake yeah he also waited with his hands
behind his back that's just natural he
likes to stand like that i mean i okay
um the
i i gotta tell a little bit of a story
here to connect
um
to what chris rock did like i
i wish
what chris rock did in terms of just
taking this lab and keep going first of
all just props for somebody that's able
to maintain cool in that situation for
the most part
i think i'd like watched it once you
only have to be alive on this planet
yeah i know too it's hard to see it you
can't avoid seeing it i wish
at that afterwards
he would sort of say something loving
and kind
to will smith
and his wife
and then hit him real hard
lean into the joke see and but there i
think in hockey they call taking a
number of a friend who plays hockey and
there's this idea that like if someone
checks you really badly in one game
you don't go and check them again you
don't get into a fight but three games
later three games you like you blade
them in the shin yeah like you so what
the the ability to defer
and to handle it in whatever fashion one
feels important they're probably also
friends and all those kinds of things
that they respect each other so he
probably didn't but there's a comedian
instinct i saw this
i was in an open mic
in uh here in texas i won't say where
there's many open mics you know you've
gone to a few of these these yeah
no so there
there is more sort of um
rougher kind of yeah you've been hanging
out in like west texas yeah
exactly austin's too tame for lex so
he's like head to west texas exactly
i put on a cowboy hat and instantly i
became a cobb we've been talking like a
cowboy
i mean i i belong out there in the
desert he's gone from eating
you know meat and athletic greens to
rattlesnakes you know
exactly right no there was a open mic is
is uh late at night and this i was one
of the only people in the audience
there's a
couple of drunk folks a few drunk folks
one of them was a couple
and
like bikers like uh with helmets and so
on a guy and a girl and then the
comedian
the open mic comedian
did a joke about people who wear helmets
i don't know if it was on purpose or not
but he did the joke and then the guy
about women who wear helmets
and the guy is this exact same situation
the guy stood up walked up to him there
was no slap it's so interesting because
this happened before the will smith
thing so he he walked up to the uh to
the comedian
and and said he like
uh
he
he i think he like pointed his finger
down and told him to stop or something
like that and then sat down this is an
audience of like six people right and
and uh at midnight around then there's
no nobody no security nothing in texas
in texas which implies oh then this guy
was the energy drunk but also a biker
and
his
where he felt his lady was now attacked
by the comedian right with his words
and this and the comedian was a kind of
out of shape
small guy
this was not threatening at all
and probably in trouble
and the comedian after he sat down he
looked a little bit scared
he paced back and forth
and then he did the joke again
wow
and i was sitting and i started i i
leaned back and i i just did this like
because that is comedy and the guy was
getting angry and angry and he just sat
there
and and uh the community went on for a
couple more minutes and then did another
bad joke but another joke about how it's
just like he leaned into it
if you go to a small comedy club open
mic or otherwise
you're in the shooting gallery like
you're basically there
teed up as a pin
to get it
uh we went and saw andrew scholes in san
francisco in san francisco yeah it was
hilarious it was amazing i mean he's
just masterful in his ability to command
an audience you know and but i felt for
the people up front but you know no
sympathy either because you know you buy
tickets to sit up front
at a shoals show you know you're going
to get it but he was very loving yeah
and funny first of all he's funny the
funniness really helps you but the the
the ethic of the comedian is like that
fearlessness i what i really liked
this is like the the danger there's risk
to comedy and there's also consequences
have you watched that show the um what
is it the marvelous miss maisel show
it's really good um i watched a few of
them um guilty pleasure there
she plays a comic in the i think it's
the mid 1960s in
in new york and um and there's a
character that somewhat resembles lenny
bruce that's sort of meant to be lenny
bruce um and
they're always getting arrested and this
this kind of thing i think i learned
about it from joe anyway it's the
writing is great it's very funny um
but yeah comedy's designed to push
boundaries right and to get and to say
the thing that you know uh other people
aren't
feel they can't say not something in
science right science you're supposed to
etiquette is a big part of how you
communicate ideas it's about
constraining
communication this is something i mean i
confess on the podcast in the goals of
making it clear
uh
interesting surprising and actionable
you know you have to constrain the
amount and the style of information
otherwise it becomes something else
altogether
right
i saw sandra burchai google ceo
said that he likes uh the thing you
mentioned
not the yoga nitro but the the an nsdr
non-sleep deep breast uh podcast over
meditation
i don't know if you saw that yeah i saw
that yeah yeah yeah uh why what what do
you think that is what anything the
difference is yeah so non-sleep deep
rest nsdr is an acronym that i coined
because it encompasses a lot of
practices that are not meditation per se
but that bring the brain and body into a
state of relaxation and focus so
hypnosis is one variant of nstr there
are other variants of nsdr you can just
look these up and you'll find them and i
think that they've caught on and that
the
google
the ceo of google uh
is an avid practitioner of nsdr
because it has this amazing ability to
reset your energy levels and focus
whereas with meditation many people find
meditation hard and part of the reason
they find it hard is that it requires
focus nsdr is a state which is very
calm and relaxing you don't have to work
too hard you're just listening to a
script whereas most forms of meditation
not all but most forms of meditation
involve cranking up the activity in your
prefrontal cortex
and
trying to see your thoughts as opposed
to thinking your thoughts or
focus on your breath but then third
personing
yourself in some respect and that's work
and so many people who meditate quite
intensely feel more exhausted now that
doesn't mean that meditation doesn't
have any utility but it's distinctly
different than nsdr and i think that
people are working certainly the ceo of
google aftermath is working very hard
and using his forebrain if he's going to
have 20 or 30 minutes to take a break
he should and i think this is what he's
doing he should go out for a jog and not
listen to anything and just kind of let
his mind wander or sit there in a chair
and just zone out or do nsdr the problem
is
people are not that good at shifting
states
we are all actually pretty good at even
people with severe
adhd we did an episode about this
can become hyper focused on things that
they actually enjoy
because dope and most of the drugs
designed to treat adhd are drugs that
increase the levels of dopamine so when
you like something there's dopamine
release and you can focus it's when you
don't like something that's hard to
focus shifting states is hard i'm sure
you've experienced this if you've ever
been in deep research or podcasting
podcasting and then all of a sudden you
go for a run you probably spend the
first third of that run thinking and
then in the middle 30 you're kind of
that thinking is is fractured a bit and
then in the final third is where you
finally get to relax because the brain
doesn't shift states very quickly we can
go from sleep to wakefulness quickly we
can go from wakefulness to sleep quickly
but we don't shift between different
states of consciousness like a step
function
except in rare cases right fear is one
all of a sudden we hear an explosion
right now it's a step function we're in
fear or we're in alertness right um a
heightened state of alertness but nsdr
is terrific at allowing people to learn
to shift their state and i actually
would venture to argue that
part of the value of meditation and
exercise is the actual state that you
get into in deep meditation or exercise
but just as valuable is the transition
that you have to take yourself through
from one state of mind to the other and
then back again i when i look you know
david goggins he always seems to come up
but he because he represents so many
important things drive determination
override of emotional state
going from being a 300 pound plus person
to a fit person through he's never
revealed anything
substantial about what he ate or what he
didn't he basically says like listen run
a lot eat less right
but what's remarkable is
so much of what he says is about those
transitions about taking oneself from a
state of i don't want to to
scruffing oneself like you're going to
do it anyway and then being able to
carry that into into regular life so to
speak so i think that um
nsdr is immensely powerful it's zero
cost and one of the reasons i'm such a
fan of people doing it is that most
people don't stick to a meditation
practice there are also been a few cases
you might find this interesting there's
a book by scott carney i forget what
it's called i think it's called the
transcendence trap or something i'm
going to have that title wrong but
there have been a fair number of cases
of people that go and do very extensive
meditation
silent meditation retreats who then
return to normal life and end up killing
themselves
there are states of mind inside of
extended meditations or silent
meditations that are very beneficial and
i'm certainly not suggesting people
don't meditate but i know at least one
person who came back from one of these
long extended meditation retreats and
wasn't able to shift their state back
into one that was functional in regular
life and that book includes a very
dramatic story i don't want to give it
away in case people
check out the book but scott told the
story to me directly once
where
someone feels they've reached
enlightenment
and then commits suicide
so these very unusual brain states are
are potentially hazardous if people
can't return from them
so it's nice to focus not on those brain
states but instead on the shifting right
i do this morning i woke up a little bit
earlier than i would have liked i use
this reverie app that's research backed
rev ri.com there's a free version of it
and or you can try it for free so i feel
that's fine
for hypnosis and i do a self-hypnosis
to put me back into sleep and if i can't
sleep just put me into a state of deep
relaxation i would i would put um
hypnosis under the category of nsdr yoga
nidra under the category of nstr there
are now some nsdr scripts online if you
just go to youtube that are you can just
listen to and do you like those i do
yeah i think the one from made4 is quite
good i have an affiliation with them but
it's free so i feel comfortable
mentioning it i do i i really like the
reverie app um i can very and as you the
more you do them the more quickly you
can shift your brain into a state of
deep relaxation i will sometimes stop
mid podcast if if it's sometimes our
recordings to go seven eight hours and
i'll stop and i'll do a one minute
hypnosis they have one minute hypnosis
inside reverie you're only going to
you're only going to find that one
minute hypnosis is effective if you are
routinely doing 10 and 15 minute
hypnosis
in addition to that meaning i do it
every other day or so at 10 or 15 so
there's a is there a youtube uh one
minute hypnosis or is this there are but
inside of reverie as well you can find
them online a really good pull it up
sorry please um yeah so reverie's good
and then michael seeley s-e-a-l-e-y
he has some long hypnosis scripts but
again these are all free and
you know there's a lot of good research
now on the neural networks and it shifts
your so-called default network default
mode network it shifts how much of your
forebrain you're using and it also is
very very good if you i get so many
questions about
hey i'm really upset i found out about
my girlfriend's sexual past or hey i'm
so upset i found out that my boyfriend
was cheating or oh so-and-so died how do
i get over these emotions how do i deal
with them and hypnosis has shown to be
very useful for people to learn to bring
themselves into a state of deep
relaxation to literally project in their
mind's eye
these very intense things that they
don't like
and then for people to associate with
other emotions in their body to learn to
be calm while feeling your feelings
to dissociate the mind-body
communication to some extent just
observe the feelings observe them and
start to associate them with positive
experiences you're an android guy so
soon it should be available on android
and then it doesn't exist for me yeah i
know
uh you know i don't get android is the
device of the people all you elitist
people with your iphone but tell me this
about android now now you want to this
is the one thing that gets me yeah
because i'm very close to someone who
uses an android phone i feel like that
so you you have great people in your
life that's good to know no their
messages always look green to me but i
answer yours not despite that um but
they
i feel like the android phones are very
trigger happy like anything i touch does
something whereas the apple phone is
kind of built for like a macaque monkey
to be able to operate which is great for
me because i'm more of a cat monkey and
you're a more sophisticated ape oh i see
i see it i think like you have to be
they're more sensitive yeah you have to
have you know i mean i've got fat
fingers you know i've got clumsy fingers
yeah
the android is is too well maybe you
need to soften your touch what i would
do is go into the most sort by most
popular
um because there's some older ones that
i really like and it generally scales
with that so i'll do the um this one the
hypnosis for clearing subconscious um
negativity that's an hour-long one the
sleep and anxiety one 40 minutes but
those you listen to as you fall asleep
as you fall asleep but we're gonna do
this now yeah let's listen to it and i
have created this hypnosis recording for
you
to help you and this is the voice how
often does the voice pop up
and at the same time you don't watch it
you just listen to your anxiety
now one of the most important things
the outset of any self-hypnosis
experience is to know and understand
hypnosis people really should know that
stage hypnosis
is about the hypnotist getting you to do
things you wouldn't normally do
self-hypnosis which is what we're
talking about here reverie in this is
about
you getting your brain into the state
that you want
and um again i mean there's a ton of
neuroimaging data and work on trauma and
pain relief and our labs are working on
this with david spiegel's lab i i really
encourage people to explore nsdr and if
this feels a little too wacky and out
there then i would just put in nsdr
into youtube and there's some good nstr
scripts yes that's by the way uh sanders
is a fan of your podcast no that's okay
we don't need to play yeah so i don't
know him and um uh but i would yeah a
lot of uh media outlets picked up on his
love of nsdr and i have to imagine
running google involves a lot of
juggling a lot of he's one of the great
ceos because everybody loves them
everybody loves them have you
interviewed him no but we'll do the
interview eventually so it's this
annoying thing about me being a stickler
for three hours
ceos don't seem to understand like not
understand but it's scheduling so what
happens is saunders said yes definitely
let's do it i'm a fan of podcasts as a
fan of yours and and and then it goes to
his executive assistant like oh let's
find a slot
and then they immediately think all
right well one hour it's good 45 minutes
90 minutes by zoom 90 minutes yeah right
well no they know in person i'm sticking
on that but like it's like no we need
more
and it's so hard to to
do you still travel to do your podcast
or generally no most people come down
here most people uh but for certain
situations obviously um like if you're
in prison
right um
or you're ahead of me if you get out on
work for a lot of people have anklets so
that they can go to the lex friedman
podcast it probably happened have you
ever been in a prison
no
you know
either a visitation or on the inside
from my hike i can see san quentin it's
really weird that san quentin and
alcatraz you know bay area beautiful
everyone thinks you know like there's
the bay and there's
alcatraz and san quentin sitting right
there does that make you feel um
you know it's amazing how easy it is to
overlook that they're there and forget
that they're there but when i drive by
san quentin i i think about it um i also
think about the people who are in there
who might be innocent
i've seen some of those episodes on
rogan and elsewhere
and amanda knox talks a lot about this
right whether or not you believe her
story or not i happen to believe her
story uh personally based on what i know
um
you know i'm sure there are people
disagree with me i think to myself what
it must be like to be in a cell
and know in your heart's heart you
didn't do it
you know i mean i can't think of i can't
think of many things worse
i can't think of many things worse
that's so clearly
unjust but life is full of
unjust things like this
cruel things
happen all the time you lose a loved one
for no good reason
you lose your job
um
you lose your home
yeah i've been talking to a lot of
refugees now and uh the war in ukraine
has really focused my mind to how much
suffering there is in the world
and so just cruel things happen all the
time and and people kind of
there's the suffering and you you kind
of go on
you stick to the people really close to
you
there's still love
all around you
traumatic events kind of focus your mind
on this like
very practical like
okay how do we solve the problem how do
we escape let's salt like survival food
shelter focus remember that book um
all's quiet on the western front by
world war one there's this line in there
i forget what it is about how war is
like the smell of a skunk
like a little bit is actually a little
is slightly um
there's something slightly delicious of
it is what it says in the in the book um
i happen to like the smell of like
ferrets and skunks and things i had a
pet ferret when i was a kid and i like
that musky scent people most people just
it's repulsive to them it's actually a
gene believe it or not some people have
the gene that makes that
the musky scent repulsive some people
love it
um
let me ask you this there's another gene
this is a fun one um microwave popcorn
smells good neutral or disgusting to you
good very good there are people who have
a gene that
leads them to the perception that the
smell of microwave popcorn that you find
is good it smells like putrid vomit to
them it's a particular
gene variant
and they can smell certain elements
within the microwave popcorn
it's pretty it's prominent in france the
uh this gene and um so in laboratories
where
uh you have a lot of french people it's
often said like you're not allowed to
make microwave popcorn smells putrid
disgusting you know so a lot of it's in
the perception of the beholder right
uh
but okay
before i leave the nsdr is uh focus in
general
as you said it's for shifting mind
states
is there advice you have for
how to achieve focus
on a task
yes
first of all we have to distinguish
between modulators and mediators and
i'll do this very briefly
there are a lot of things that will
modulate your state of focus but they
don't directly mediate your sense of
focus so for instance if right now a
fire alarm went off in this building it
would modulate our attention we would
get up and leave it'd be very hard to do
what we're doing with that banging in
the background at least at first
so it's modulating focus but it's not
really
involved in the mechanisms of focus
right
in the same way being well rested when
you sleep your autonomic nervous system
that adjusts states of alertness and
focus and calm works better than when
you're sleep-deprived so if you're
sleeping better you're going to focus
better so i always answer this way uh to
a question like this because
the best thing that anyone can do for
their mental health physical health and
performance in athletic or cognitive
endeavors or creative endeavors is to
make sure that you're getting enough
quality sleep
enough of the time for you and that's
going to differ we could talk about what
that means now in terms of things that
mediate focus
without getting in the description of
mechanisms because we have podcasts
about that
it's very clear that mental focus
follows visual focus provided that
you're a sighted person
much of the training that's being done
now in china to teach kids to focus
better literally has them stare at a
target
blinking every so often but really
training themselves to breathe calmly
and maintain a tight visual aperture
when you read you have to maintain a
tight visual aperture you're literally
scrolling like a highlighter in your
mind's eye right it's kind of obvious
once you hear it so for people that have
problems focusing sleep well
learn to dilate and contract your visual
field consciously this can be done
if you practice it a little bit and then
be as i said before it is very hard to
get into a state of focus like a step
function immediately like snapping your
fingers what you can do is you can pick
any object but ideally an object at
roughly the same distance
placed it roughly the same distance to
which you're going to do that work and
stare at it you're allowed to blink and
as your mind starts to drift every once
in a while to understand that's normal
but try and narrow your visual aperture
and bring that into your
visual field so that that's the most
prominent thing kind of like portrait
mode in your phone this would look very
different in portrait mode than it would
in just a standard photograph mode
and then after doing that for 30 to 60
seconds
moving into the work that you're about
to do and really encourage yourself to
do that
if you're somebody who's low vision or
no vision you're going to use your ears
to do this braille readers have trouble
focusing sometimes because they feel
other stuff and they hear other stuff so
you learn to adjust that aperture
consciously
and then of course the pharmacologic
tools just enough caffeine but not too
much right um we've talked about white
noise brown noise music or no music
really varies but it's very clear that
binaural beats
of 40 hertz
can shift the brain into a heightened
state of focus and cognition so if
you're going to use binaural beats which
should definitely be used with
headphones
and there are a number of free apps out
there in sources uh 40 hertz seems to be
the
frequency that
best supports the brain shifting into a
particular can you give us the some some
some binaural beats yeah so you're going
to look for you'd want to find a
an app that offers 40 hertz i think
brainwave
allows you to um
slide bar up
to the particular frequency that you
want and i should say that um there are
other frequencies that are interesting
but 40 hertz binaural beat seems to be
the one that there's the most quality
research on so there's a it's like it's
like a b yeah um yeah yeah but you're
saying there's a lot of mixed science on
the on the
yeah brought white noise and broad noise
you really should be doing this with
headphones because binaural beats are
best accomplished by feeding two
different frequencies to the two ears
and then you have what's called the this
brain stem area that reads out what are
called interaural time differences and
then it extracts the
the delta essentially turn
and then in other things that can
enhance focus so you know the
pharmacology around this is pretty
interesting things that tickle the
dopamine pathway and the acetylcholine
by the way they work yeah um there's
your ritalin your adderalls your
modafinils which are prescription and
there's a lot of
non-prescription use of those
prescription drugs not so much in my
generation but in people 35 and younger
you know i hear all the time from day
traders and programmers and stuff and
kids that play video games a lot of
ritalin adderall use
i think that unless it's prescribed by a
doctor for a specific purpose of adhd i
don't think people should go that route
frankly hits the dopamine system way too
hard also
has a number of negative effects on
sexual side effects all sorts of things
that you just wouldn't want
there are a few compounds like alpha gpc
um 300 milligrams to 600 milligrams of
alpha gpc with a cup of espresso if
you're well rested you're like a laser
for 90 minutes maybe two hours but then
it's going to taper off and you have to
just recognize that and then there's
this whole world of nootropics now and
people trying to figure out the racetams
peracetams and phenylethylamine combined
with this and you know it's not quite in
the place where you'd like it to be
there are a few companies that are doing
this better than others we talked about
some of these on the podcast but um
i would always start with behavioral
tools and then consider pharmacology and
and then i suppose the the other thing
for focus is um they're these this is a
little more esoteric but uh we covered
this in an episode on workplace
optimization
um where you place your screen is
important staring down at a screen is
not going to be as effective as placing
it eye level or above you when the eyes
are up literally your eyes are directed
forward or up the brainstem centers for
alertness are activated when your eyes
are down it's actually you're you're
sort of it's like being pulled under
water a little bit in the autonomic
arousal sense it's you're closing your
eyes i mean um
is one
it reflects the brain stem centers that
are active becoming less refrec for
alertness excuse me becoming less active
but there's a really cool effect that's
active in this room right now which is
that there's been some really
interesting studies that when people
work in small compact spaces or wear a
hoodie or a hat that can also
improve focus like blinders on a horse
for obvious reasons now based on what i
said before but also
analytic work or the kind of work where
there's a correct answer that you're
seeking
is best supported by these kind of low
ceiling environments whereas there's
something called the cathedral effect
which is when you work in an outdoor
environment or a high ceiling
environment it lends itself to kind of
pun intended kind of loftier ideas and
more creativity and that probably has to
do with the fact that there's a natural
tendency a reflex to expand your visual
field in these high ceiling environments
expansion of the visual field
changes the way the brain works in the
time domain your engineering and biology
oriented
listeners will understand this for the
music
for those that don't
the best way to think about it is when
you have a narrow focus portrait mode on
your phone or you're very alert you are
fine slicing
life in time it's like a um think of it
as a high frame rate like you're
shooting in slow motion
when you have a uh when you dilate your
v your view you're taking bigger time
bins and the one way to just let this
hopefully land home is that if you've
ever had a really exciting day or
podcast interview or experience of any
kind your system is flooded with
dopamine and norepinephrine alertness
and motivation all this excitement it
seems like it goes by very very fast and
yet when you think back to that it seems
like a lot happened this happened then
that happened now think about waiting in
the doctor's office in a blank waiting
room with no interesting art on the
walls
it feels like it goes by very very slow
dopamine and norepinephrine are all time
low
and yet when you think back on that
experience it's as if nothing happened
because you were
you were parsing time differently
so those are the roughly the tools and
the and the neurochemicals around time
perception and the time domain uh
there's a wonderful book i'm forgetting
the title so wonderful i forget the
title by dean umano from ucla but i
think it's called the brain is a time
machine
that talks about this expansion and
contraction of the time domain and what
you can do to leverage it for work and
creativity focus and so on yeah it's
fascinating that i think one way to
define focus for me is
uh to the experience the feeling of
focus is losing track of time
is getting to a place where you're no
longer up
operating in time
well and you mentioned being you know
kind of uh cramming for for something
you'll release a lot of adrenaline and
you'll it is true you can get a lot done
under pressure because of the way that
you're slicing time you don't actually
have more time it's that you're finally
in a brain state that lends itself well
to
parsing information really quickly now
if we ramp up your level of stress
enough it's definitely a you know it's a
more or less normal distribution we get
you stressed enough it's hard to
remember anything you're not parsing
time well but in that middle range
almost every study shows that the higher
levels of autonomic arousal meaning
norepinephrine adrenaline in your system
the more effective you are at things and
we you know we always hear stress and
adrenaline it's just bad bad bad but my
colleague ali krom at stanford has done
these beautiful studies where if you
just educate people on how adrenaline
makes them
sharper thinkers
they become sharper thinkers if you
educate them on the fact that stress
makes your cognition worse their
cognition gets worse this is why i don't
wear a sleep tracker if you tell people
they slept poorly your recovery score
sucks
they naturally perform less well the
next day than if you tell them your
recovery score is high and so i don't
have anything against those companies
but i in fact we use some of their
technology can be very useful in certain
contexts but
you want to determine your
your mindset around these things and if
you tell yourself hey deadlines make me
sharp pressure makes me sharp you will
perform better so stress and anxiety
what is that and can it be leveraged for
good
absolutely stressing luke whether or not
you get into a cold ice bath or a or a
hot sauna so hot you want to get out or
you
get hit square in the face with
something over text that you really
didn't want to hear or see
it's adrenaline it's just adrenaline and
so your subjective readout of that and
what it means is really important and
you can just channel that well you can
if you if you
agree with the following statement which
i do and many people do because the data
support it which is ali chrome's
statement not mine which is she directs
the mind body lab at stanford she's
brilliant by the way um brilliant
harvard trained yale trained
trained licensed clinical psychologist
also tenured professor she's an uh uh
olympian uh no excuse me a division one
athlete in gymnastics and uh martial
arts and her dad um is a long-time
martial arts trainer he's done work with
special forces he's an amazing human
being and very humble very kind lovely
woman and professor scientist she says
anything that you do and experience but
especially stress
is the consequence of that thing and
what you believe about that thing and so
if you consume a lot of information
about the powers of stressful states to
bring out your best you will perform
better if you consume a lot of
information about the power of stress to
[ __ ] you you will perform worse
there's absolutely no question the data
are striking and this is not growth
mindset this is just simply what sorts
of what do you believe about stress
based on the
dominant knowledge that you're consuming
about it so that's why it's fun to watch
david
goggins here we go again david or jocko
or or joe or someone put where cam
haines you know put out this information
about or ryan hall who ran for stanford
and then now is like into the power
lifting thing and running you know
and there are others too of course
when you start to consume a lot of that
information it's not just inspiring it
actually changes your perception of what
your own stressful states mean
they
you can actually get better from stress
if you're
in the ocean of knowledge that stress
grows you if you're in the ocean of
living in the ocean of knowledge i was
thinking like a pool in the summer you
got the kiddie pool the kids all peeing
in it presumably you got the diving
thing you got the high dive and all that
if you believe that
the experience of belly flopping off the
high dive is going to make you a better
diver
in some sense it at least in this
analogy it will
whereas if you feel that it's just the
most embarrassing thing ever and it's
going to [ __ ] your ability to get out
in the dive in front of anybody ever
again well you're you're right about
that too
yeah we uh actually talk with carl about
depression all those kinds of things
that there could be
these
what are commonly seen as negative
journeys that could be
when reframed
can be used you know one of the reasons
i enjoy our friendship so much is that
you bring this russian thing
you know which i don't really understand
it at a deep level how could i i'm not
russian but um
but this mindset like that there's pain
in life when i watched that uh hedgehog
in the fog
cartoon i thought no wonder russians the
way they do this is the most it's so sad
it's beautiful and savage so sad whereas
out here it's like sesame street and you
know my mother would not let me watch
sesame street when i was a kid yes she
thought it was too chaotic
she's chaos too chaotic she was like
it's too chaotic too many things going
on captain kangaroo we were allowed and
then mr rogers we were loud i never
really liked shows i liked doing things
in outside in the in the yard um i was
trying to trap all the animals i didn't
want to watch stuff on tv but you know
hedgehog in the fog is enough to turn
any kid into a thinker and a philosopher
and a poet
here we go
i fell in love with this when when you
showed look it even walks with its arms
behind its back so for people don't know
and we're watching little clips here to
get into and it's a hedgehog
that
is wandering about in this fog at night
and can't even see a lamp the fog is so
and there's a there's a feeling of
searching
and then there's a there's a horse that
speaks from from a distance
words of wisdom some people actually
told me that they believe that's god
that's supposed to represent
god i always thought it was a motherly
voice or a voice
a voice of conformity that wants you to
return to safety and here's a
the hedgehog is searching
for something that's in him
for the unknown to the explore the
unknown and ultimately as it
um
as the cartoon unrolls it's
he discovers a friend
in a bear
and he also discovers a lifetime passion
for looking up at the stars and the
curiosity of exploring what is up there
and i see that as science as exploring
the mystery
and also i see that as brave
to explore the mystery given all the
uncertainty all around you but there is
a melancholy the whole sound of it the
feel of it the look of it it was um
it just captures
both the melancholy and the wander of
childhood
which is like there's a loneliness to it
like nobody understands me
uh
that's there that that children can can
can feel because you're you're trying to
figure out my favorite character right
there i love the owl i love the owl
the owl shows up every once in a while i
love the owl sorry i interrupted you
there's again there's non-sequitur it
means you're interested seventy percent
of the time
the other thirty percent you're just an
[ __ ] so you have to figure out
there's non-secure parts in this cartoon
it's it's voda is one of the greatest
cartoons of all time short short little
films documentary filmmakers it's a it
is uh you know in the soviet union in
in a lot of sort of
authoritarian regimes
there's channels to communicate
difficult ideas
to people and you figure out those
channels and in soviet union one of
those channels was
children's cartoons
so actually they're very much for adults
yeah i i like that um
in some countries not so much in the us
children are treated with more respect
for their intelligence you know
and not constantly getting this drivel
of of just kind of moronic explosions
and whistles and bells and the voices
that um just kind of you know children
obviously are children and need to be
their brains are young and plastic and
need to be
treated and nurtured
uh as such but
they
but they have an intelligence and i
think that um
you treat them like morons and and
they're gonna behave like morons you
treat them as you know people who can
uh
consume information and make sense of it
in their own way and
that's what they're gonna do they have a
seriousness of looking at the world i
love people
that talk with children like they're
adults
we'll just like here's if you're talking
to minnie einstein
because you're like really
uh they're asking some big questions and
i think uh i mean people sometimes
uh speak of me in this way like
how dumb is this childlike person but
like no no there's intelligence in these
dumb simple questions
in like that a child asks and i always
love those questions the simplicity but
also the depth of the those those
questions the
reason i started watching your podcast
was you did an episode early on with ray
dalio yeah and
the first maybe the first but a question
that you definitely asked him was you
just said
what is money
and his answer was fantastic it's an
it's a superb question and he gave a
superb answer
and
i never would have thought to ask that
question
and it's it's the question and it was
the question to tee things off with
um
so simple
questions that get right to the heart of
the matter
you know and kids aren't
often putting the same uh cultural
filters and um
you know they're not kids gen generally
aren't concerned about getting canceled
either
so they'll ask the question that no one
else is willing to ask and they're not
concerned about the how
dumb the question
sounds i find the most fascinating
questions it's just really really simple
and it is a bit embarrassing
to ask those simple questions of what
like what is well anything you're asking
them for all of us so please ask them um
i think that question what is money is
crucial and
i think the simple questions are the
most obviously the most interesting one
i got to ask you about you had awesome
podcasts i mean i can ask you questions
about basically all your products people
should definitely listen to the
kubernetes but uh with with any gap in
the conversation
uh he talked about strength and muscle
building all that kind of stuff he's an
encyclopedia yeah and he also works with
a lot of ufc fighters and he works with
he has a lab that includes a gym and so
he works on endurance and powerlifting
and also hypertrophy training etc but he
also does muscle biopsy so he runs the
full spectrum and he's a full tenured
professor and he does all this stuff so
he's he's a
really unique um person in this whole
fitness landscape because there are a
lot of pts out there there are a lot of
kinesiologists there are a lot of people
studying nutrition and sports training
but he i think he has the among the
people out there he's at least in the
top five
probably within the top three of people
that really have their arms around the
full extent of what's possible with with
training and um and he works with the
ufc performance center i mean he just
said a very systematic way of describing
things that was really nice
you know um skill speed power strength
uh hypertrophy so
muscle mass right
endurance all kinds of and then the
philosophical of like adaptation how to
overload stuff all that very is there
stuff
i'll ask you about ice bath and sauna
which was surprising to me there is
there stuff you took away
from that conversation
like principles
about how to get strong
how to build muscle mass
that like broaden and deepen your
understanding of that task
definitely and i'll do these in bullet
points because if people want the logic
behind them in the mechanism they can
listen to that episode that's a really
good episode i'll start with heat and
cold really quickly and just say that
avoid cold immersion so ice baths and
being in cold water up to the neck
uncomfortably cold within the four hours
after a
training session that's designed to
evoke an adaptation either endurance
hypertrophy or strength because the
inflammation that you experience from a
hard endurance workout or from a heart
strength or a hypertrophy workout is the
stimulus by that you're going to adapt
to the cold water immersion reduces
inflammation
and can short-circuit some of that
after four hours you're probably okay
but if you can do it a different day or
you can do it before those sessions
that's better heat
however can be done immediately after
training and it's probably beneficial
because of the way that it dilates the
vascular system and delivers perfuses
the muscles and ligaments etc with more
nutrients and i should just mention that
was
a crucial piece of information it's a
little bit surprising was it surprising
to you absolutely because i actually the
way i posed the question to him about
cold was i hear that getting into an ice
bath or a cold water immersion after
training can reduce hypertrophy but i'm
guessing it's not that big of a deal and
he said no it is a big deal it will
short-circuit your progress now for
people that are only interested in
performance who are doing a lot of
workouts and trying to recover but not
trying to grow muscle get stronger or
build endurance then it makes sense to
do cold because skill development skill
development or you're an athlete in
season
you know so you have to
what's so great about andy is he really
points out the specific ways to train
given your specific goals so forgetting
swole stay out of the ice bath after a
workout there you go lex is always
making fun of the meat heads i love it
um i put myself in the meathead category
only because i don't do a real sport now
i work out and i run um which is an
aspiring meathead okay so one of these
days i'm going to get back to juices or
i'm going to get two jiu jitsu now in
terms of training he has this beautiful
three by five concept for strength
pick three exercises compound exercises
multi-joint movements
do them for
do three to five exercises
for three to five repetitions
per set
rest three to five minutes and do that
three to five times per week and for
details you can again look to the
episode it's time stamped but what's
interesting about this is three to five
times a week is a lot for a muscle group
squatting three five times a week for
five reps meaning you're working pretty
heavy
meaning you're close to failure but not
failure on for strength generally
what andy taught me is that
people who are training mostly for
strength can do these low rep type
regimens
frequently because most of the
adaptation is neural and because you're
not pushing to failure in most cases
you don't get that sore and so it's the
motor neurons getting the muscle fibers
to contract more intensely or with more
efficiency in other ways that's leading
to these strength gains and this is why
power lifters can train every day or
five days a week or four days a week
for hypertrophy
i learned from andy that the repetition
range can be pretty broad you think
anywhere from 6 to 30 repetitions
you should do 10 sets per muscle group
per week maybe even a bit more so high
volume high volume
but
you have to go to failure or beyond in
order to stimulate growth why does it
work at such a great range of
repetitions well there apparently are
three ways that you stimulate
hypertrophy and maybe more one is tissue
micro damage to the tissue the other is
through some sort of tension-based
changes in the molecular
gene programs of cells that lead to
protein synthesis that don't that are
distinct from damage and the other
metabolic effects of like high
repetition work of superfusion of the
muscle with blood we know that third
category exists because people are now
doing this blood restriction training
where they cuff off a muscle and they'll
use a really light weight i've done
these before you can use a five pound
weight and do curls with this and you're
you are in pain and the muscles are
swelling up with blood it does lead to
hypertrophy but
in general you're not sore you're not
doing tissue damage and by the way don't
just turn the kid off a muscle because
you have to use the proper cuffs um
because you need the blood still to flow
in one direction you can't just cinch it
off or you'll potentially kill yourself
if you um get a clot or you do it wrong
so get the appropriate cuffs they're out
there
and then for endurance i learned
something really cool so i i work out
basically i go to the gym
every other day on average three or four
days a week i do that but generally not
two days in a row it's work out next day
i'll do cardio next day and the cardio
for me is always a 30 to 45 minute jog
kind of zone 2 cardio
andy informed me that to build endurance
while building strength and maintaining
some muscle size or even building muscle
size
i would be wise to take one day a week
and add to that
all out
max heart rate work for 90 seconds
at least so do 90 seconds then rest and
then maybe do another 90 second all-out
sprint i almost missed my flight going
from los angeles to austin i did that
all out sprint in the airport
yesterday so i actually since i think
it's done for me so there was a
sprinting
dr hubermann thrall with three bags
that's awesome because i travel i
generally i i'll travel with um too much
stuff um i love how you were probably
running late for a flight and used that
as an opportunity to explo well as i was
doing it i was thinking to myself okay
andy that's a 90 second sprint because i
got to the the security line i finally
got tsc but that's for better that's for
extending endurance that's for yeah it
actually has some carryover effects on
endurance if you're doing the other
stuff and then he also said one day a
week to do this workout and i haven't
done it yet maybe do it tomorrow it'd be
fun which is you run a mile
you
ask yourself how long did that take
let's say it took eight minutes then you
walk or rest for eight minutes then you
run another mile
as fast as you can and then you rest for
the equivalent period and you do that
one to three times once per week so
and so as an all-around fitness program
it make you could collapse this into
something where you say okay you can
work out with the weights for about an
hour every other day maybe take two days
off every once in a while maybe not
you're going to do
six to 15 repetitions you're gonna push
to failure on some of those not all
because some of those are designed to
build more strength you're not going to
failure and heavier some are designed
for hypertrophy higher rep and going to
failure and then on off days you're
going to jog for 30 to 45 minutes but
for two days a week you're either at the
end of your jog
or whatever you're gonna do some all-out
sprint for 90 seconds and then
rest and repeat and for another day
you're going to do
these mile repeats
that's a pretty that's a pretty large
chunk of exercise movement but if you
kind of thread through the middle of all
that what you end up with is some decent
strength building protocols some decent
hypertrophy some cardiovascular training
that establishes the so-called a base or
a so-called base so you're not going to
get really good at anything you're not
going to become a marathoner this way an
optimizing marathon you're not going to
optimize powerlifting you're not going
to optimize hypertrophy but for the
typical person 75 of people 75 of the
time they want some muscle they want
some strength they want some endurance
and they want the capacity to sprint to
the to the security gate without um you
know leaving a lung in the terminal so
it's like functional stuff like your
life going up the stairs is easier yeah
moving about yeah kind of just regular
yeah and i should mention that cold
showers after
training don't seem to short-circuit the
um
the training effect to the same extent
that immersion in cold water does and
that really speaks to the fact that cold
showers even though they can provide
some of the adrenaline for the mental
effects of like oh i have a lot of
adrenaline my system from a cold shower
and i can remain calm there's utility to
that
it's not going to have the same
metabolic effects or other positive
effects that cold water exposure has
been shown to have
and
that's unfortunate because most people
have access to cold showers not everyone
has access to a cold dunk or a nice
stunk but here in um austin you have
this place and no they don't pay me to
say this but i always like going to this
place whenever i'm telling this place
kuya and they've got a sauna and a
couple ice baths and they even have
those salt tanks that you can float on
the surface baths there they have cold
water immersion that's pretty cold still
haven't done a nice bath really too yeah
i need to yeah you're rushing you'll
probably get in and and you won't even
what is this what's the big deal exactly
or people pay for this
i did a post right of you as a baby yeah
it's you know i had to go deep to get
that photo of lex um in a bassinet in
the snow yeah
because in russia they actually did this
for a long time they thought that it
would and indeed it does build the
immune system to expose babies to the
cold i don't i still don't know where
you got that photo and you were able to
find exactly the right it was it was
great
it's great you didn't have a tie on but
you had all the look and seriousness
that you do now so it's clearly nature
nurture clearly you were born with that
what about sauna he does say that it's
good to do heat so there are three ways
you can do sauna that i can just toss
out as like brief things if you want to
get a really big growth hormone release
for sake of metabolism fat loss you're
training really really hard in jiu jitsu
and you want to recover
you don't want a sauna too often because
the study that um identified this
massive 16-fold increase in growth
hormone they had people do this it's
crazy
they got into okay temperatures are 80
to 100 degrees centigrade so that's 176
degrees fahrenheit to 212 degrees
fahrenheit
for five to 30 minutes
is the typical ranges that people work
in in these research studies
for maximum growth hormone
hormone release don't do sauna more than
once a week
but get into the sauna for 30 minutes
as hot as you can safely tolerate so
probably for you that'll be 210 because
you're i suspect you'll be on the high
end of things
then get out for five to ten minutes
no cold exposure get back in the sauna
for 30 minutes then they had them do it
again out for five minutes back for 30
minutes out for five minutes back for
three minutes they had them do two hours
of sauna exposure to get that
growth hormone release now for the
reduction in likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event stroke or otherwise
the more often you do sauna the better
so if you look at all calls all cause
mortality or death due to cardiovascular
events and you look at sauna use
frequencies using the same parameters 80
to 100 degrees centigrade
one to seven times per week basically
the more often you get into the sauna
for 30 minutes
across the week so 30 minutes a day is
better than four times a week four times
a week is better than two times a week
and two times a week is better than one
and the reductions in mortality are
really impressive
27
if you get into the sauna the way i just
described not the two hours a day but 30
minutes
twice a week or three times per week you
reduce the likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event by 27
if you do it four or more times per week
you reduce the probability of dying by
50
of a cardiovascular event and in these
studies they rule out other things that
people are doing smoking they even ask
them do you live in an apartment are you
in a happy relationship like they
evaluate other potentially confounding
variables now for people that don't have
access to a sauna a hot water bath or
hot tub is going to be your next best
bet
and if you don't have access to that do
like the wrestlers do which is you know
put on two sets of uh sweats and a
hoodie and a stocking cap and wrap
yourself in plastics underneath all that
and go for a run but don't please nobody
die of hyperthermia i mean you can die
of warming up too much is this
experience um
pleasant
or stressful
in the way so is it as stressful as an
ice bath okay great question
people always ask how cold to make the
ice bath or the cold water or the shower
you want it to be uncomfortably cold
meaning you want to feel like i really
want to get out but you can safely stay
in and that's going to vary by person
and experience with it experience yeah
with the sauna it's the same thing
how hot to make it well don't kill
yourself obviously
be smart if you're pregnant you
shouldn't be doing this anyway
but
it's very clear that what you need is
the release of something called
dinorphin we have endorphin which makes
us feel good it binds to these mu opioid
receptors in the body you have dynorphin
which is the terrible feeling that you
get when you're in really hot
temperatures it's also the terrible
effect that alcoholics feel when they
are in withdrawal you feel agitated you
want to get out it's really unpleasant
it's dinorphin binding to the so-called
kappa opioid receptor is that's what
you're trying to trigger when you do
that a number of things happen you set
off heat shock proteins that go repair
broken proteins and misfolded proteins
it also makes it so that later endorphin
binds its receptor more strongly so when
you have this uncomfortable experience
in the heat
you literally feel better in real life
when pleasurable vents come on
when you experience them in the same way
i like to say this that when you get
into a cold ice bath or cold shower the
increase in
epinephrine and dopamine is
two to three hundred percent these are
huge increases and they last many hours
this is shown
because lately i've been getting a
little bit of pushback on
twitter that which is you know um
interesting place um
people say well that's just in mice no
all the studies i just referred to are
all done in humans men and women fairly
broad age ranges so you want to be
uncomfortable in the cold you want to be
uncomfortable in the heat this is why
i'm not a big fan of infrared saunas
because they only go up to about 160 170
degrees
infrared light and far red light of all
kinds has been shown to be beneficial
for wound healing acne skin eyes there
are even guys now putting on their
testicles because it can increase
testosterone and sperm production yeah
hormone release hormone release but in
terms of the sauna you want that strong
heat stimulus yeah and that's when you
get crawl up to the 200 mark and so on
whenever i'm in new york and there's
also one in san francisco although the
one in san francisco is is clothing
optional just to warn people there's a
place called archimedes banya is there
any scientific evidence that being naked
is beneficial in the sauna well in
certain contexts it leads to um
childbirth okay i'll have to read up on
that i read that song but um i suppose
it's not required right for childbirth
but um but in all seriousness you know
in new york i'll go to a place called
spa 88 and actually uh khabib's picture
is on the wall he goes there and it's a
it there that one it's clothing they
require clothing i always just say that
because it can be a little bit of a
shock to people sometimes if they kind
of walk in there a bunch of naked people
the one in san francisco i if i go i'm
clothed mostly because you know i run
into co-workers or things like that you
know i i sort of more
old-fashioned in that way i suppose but
um do you like to wear clothes they're
on co-workers yes yeah in general yeah i
mean it's just to me it just seems like
you know that just be aware but but
nonetheless the banyas have very hot
saunas because they're russian owned and
in new york there's one on the lower
east side but the spy 88 place they have
some saunas that
the moment i get into those
i have a hard time catching a full
breath it burns they've got a cold dunk
that's like a shock and then they've got
a sauna wet sauna steam room that's a
little mellower so the nice thing about
abanya is you can kind of find your
place and then they do the plaza where
they take the eucalyptus leaves and you
can pay someone and you basically you
cover your groin and then they beat you
with the the the leaves and it's
supposed to bring the vasculature to the
surface i've only done it once and
frankly i found it to be a little bit um
unnerving i didn't really like the
experience but i i'll try and get into a
sauna as often as i possibly can which
is you know once or three times per week
and i try and do the cold
exposure shower or immersion but early
in the day because it really wakes you
up one of my favorite
things i've listened to i wish there was
a video is uh listening to a bunch of
stuff with rick rubin and um he did a
thing with tim ferriss like the tim
ferriss podcast i don't know if you've
ever heard it but
he
he forced them to do they did the
podcast in a sauna
and i don't think at the time tim
ferriss was adapted yeah if you're not
heat adapted it can be pretty stressful
and i mean obviously the whole
experience is stressful as a somebody
with with microphones like what what is
happening but i just love
that tim was vulnerable enough to kind
of
give himself over to whatever the hell
this experience is and i
i'm just so happy that rick
like pushed that kind of idea and just
let's let's do it that's a very rick
rubin kind of thing to do and we must
not we like we must do this this has to
be done a podcast that was done from
asana continuously would be really
interesting like you could call it like
the pressure cooker or something oh i
mean like a regular pocket yeah like you
have to sit with your guests in the
sauna um or they have to sit in the
sauna well that was one of the
interesting things is um
it was a sad thing because i believe
there's no video of that podcast but you
could tell
there was a kind of
there was suffering and especially
it was like a degradation he he started
over time not being able to put words
together correctly which he's very
eloquent
and so you could see
there's like
there's a struggle heat and cold pull
you down from the inside you have to i
mean there's a reason why the screening
process for
um make you know sealed steel they call
it seal training but it's really
screening and training involves cold
waters because you know if you're in the
heat too long you'll die or damage
tissue in cold you can do it quite
extensively before you die or damaged
tissue but it is stressful i was going
to say one thing that um
i sometimes enjoy seeing these social
media posts where people get into the
ice bath they'll look really stoic like
they're really tough
um but actually that's the wimpy way to
go through it
when you get into cold water if you stay
very still you develop a thermal
sheath around you
that you're warming yourself
the the really bold way is to get in and
continue to sift your arms and legs and
it ends up feeling miserably colder
and there's no sheath because you're
breaking they're bringing up that
thermal layer and then when you get out
you'll notice a lot of people huddle or
they'll they'll put or they'll grab the
towel in general that's me i'll get back
i'll get into the sauna
but if you really want to stimulate the
big increases in metabolism you stand
out there and you dry off with arms
extended
in open air and as that water evaporates
off you it is really cold but your body
is forced to activate a number of the
warming programs related to metabolism
this is the beautiful work of a woman
named susannah soberg who's scandinavian
she published this paper last year in
cell reports medicine and so i call this
the soberg principle which is if you're
doing ice and heat for whatever reason
doesn't matter if you end on heat or
cold but if you're using cold
specifically to stimulate an increase in
metabolism
end with cold that's the sobering
principle
and with cold yeah if you're alternating
and then uh if you want to do it the
tough way you let the shivering so you
just stand out and let the water
evaporate yeah i mean if you ever waded
into a cold ocean you know everybody's
kind of like holding themselves you know
if you really just if you let yourself
extend your limbs and move them around a
bit so you break up that thermal layer
uh that's that's the tough way to do it
so when i see people on social media
getting in and they're like really tough
and trying to look hard yeah you want to
be moving around yeah
smiling talking moving around is way way
colder yeah are you able to talk can you
do
so you suggest a podcast in the in the
sauna how about this i proposed this
since i got you you want to do the next
podcast i'll get two so the folks from
the plunge uh maybe could bring lexa a
plunge he certainly uh deserves one and
uh we can go side-by-side coffin style
or we can face one another well we said
we should do each other's podcasts and
maybe next year i can't wait to have you
back on i mean we only scratch the
surface well let's do at least part of
the next human lab podcast either and i
have a sauna and a cold plunge so we
could do yeah yeah we could do
in we do a sauna and a cold plunge
version i wonder the recording how the
recording works if they were a bit of an
echo in the sauna i'm sure we can take
out the reverb
uh so
sergey wants
to ask you about sex performance
uh very journalistic very hardcore
hitting questions that we have here
generally or a specific uh no he has a
certain problem he needs help with no uh
generally you haven't done an episode on
sex well we did an episode early on on
sexual development yes we've done them
on optimizing testosterone and estrogen
and we touched a little bit on the
uh on libido
and somewhat on sex performance but not
much we did an episode on relationships
love and desire where we touched on
libido specifically so just as a quick
mention of something a lot of people
take ssris or antidepressants that can
disrupt sexual function there are a few
compounds like maca root and tonga ali
and things like that that at least in a
few studies in humans have been shown to
offset some of the the sexual side
effects
um
now in terms of sexual and then sorry
the episode on sexual development was
about how the brain and body become
organized in certain ways how the brain
becomes organized if you have x
chromosomes or y chromosomes or et
cetera so early early early development
mainly and the effects of hormones later
on that template
we will be doing a i'm actually putting
together a series on sexual health
everything from
the menstrual cycle which both men and
women should understand of course um
understanding arousal
understanding for instance a lot of
people don't realize this but that
orgasm is actually the consequence of
activity in the
sympathetic meaning the stress arm of
the autonomic nervous system
whereas arousal
is the consequence of the activity of
the parasympathetic the calming aspect
of the of of the autonomy that's
counterintuitive right it's
counterintuitive and it kind of works
like a seesaw i mean there's arousal
then there's relaxation then there's
arousal but the
um and then immediately after orgasm
and in males ejaculation what ends up
happening is there's a rebounding of the
parasympathetic nervous system which it
leads to oftentimes people feeling very
relaxed or falling asleep
so
i'm going to do a short series on sexual
health that will be that will include
stuff about sexual performance but also
um
some i i'm working on getting a an
expert guest who can talk about some of
the neurologic changes that happen
um as a consequence of sexual activity
and we did an episode with uh a guy from
ut austin here david buss who's
evolutionary psychologist talking about
um
we went pretty deep into some of the uh
typical and unusual dynamics of of
mating relation
whether or not people have kids or not
and what impacts that but we're going to
do an episode on menopause andropause
what's very surprising is i get a lot of
questions about sexual health from the
young male audience
[Music]
which tells me that
well here's what i think it reflects i
think that women because of their
menstrual cycles early on start to talk
to one another about changes in
physiology and psychology as a function
of this 28 day cycle that they all
experience sooner or later
males there's less of a conversation and
it usually arrives in code people say
hey what should i take to increase my
testosterone and i'll say well maybe
nothing you know
what are you specifically concerned
about and then over time if you pull on
those threads a little bit you you know
you get your answer sometimes i'll just
get a direct question um but i think
that uh
the psychology of all this and in terms
of jealousy and the terms of
notions of roles and relationships is
very dynamic right now and i'm
fascinated by this so we're going to do
a four episode series what about sexual
fantasy
what uh to get freudian for a second
what role does sexual fantasy have
in the human condition there's a book
called the erotic imagination it's a
very psychoanalytic book written by a
psychoanalyst that talks about um how
well here's the uncomfortable reality
freud was at least right about one thing
which is that the brain circuitry that
you used
to develop attachments to your
caregivers mother and father or other
caregivers
do not disappear when you hit puberty
they are repurposed for romantic and
sexual relations
and so this is why the whole notion of
anxious attached and secure attached you
know stems from childhood attachment
patterns but it carries over to romantic
relationships
so that the relationship with your
mother has
and father has a
and probably other close people to you
and your young age has
a
secondary tertiary some kind of ripple
effect on how your sexuality developed
like what fantasies you might have all
that oh without question and of course
early experiences too and traumatic or
positive or neutral the thing that's
really important to remember though in
this transfer of circuitry from one role
to another is that
and it's certainly consistent with
psychoanalysis that gender is
interchangeable
sex is interchangeable so for instance
let's say you had a wonderful
relationship let's say this let's take a
hypothetical person okay i'm truly not
referring to myself let's take a a a
young woman who has a wonderful
relationship to her father
and a just absolutely terrible abusive
relationship to her mother just for sake
of example
she then goes into adulthood and
she is drawn to very abusive
men not always but let's just use in
this example
and the dynamic is exactly the same as
the dynamic she had with her mother
that's actually a common occurrence even
though
in this context she's heterosexual she's
romantically attracted to men what is
seen over and over again is that the
dynamic with one parent can be
transferred onto a romantic dynamic but
it doesn't have to be you know that if
it was with the mother then it only has
to do with relationships to women so
gender is interchangeable because these
circuitries
are pre-sexual they're laid down in our
brain before the brain has any concept
of sexual interactions
it's pre-pubertal excuse me
and so um there are a lot of interesting
examples and data to support this
the book attached is a pretty
interesting book by two psychologists
one i think is at columbia university um
that talks about how childhood dynamics
uh carry over to adult uh romantic
attachment so as you can tell i get
pretty alert in response to these
questions i get a lot of them really in
this domain and they have a lot of
impact on people and they're wondering
about they want to learn and no one
knows what other people are doing or
what's normal we kind of know deviancy
we know perversion we know the extremes
yeah we know the rules hopefully people
know the rules but
you know
let's just be there are a lot of people
in in the academic community in
particular at certain east coast schools
not to be named that are in open
relationships this is more common now
um it's not
very common but it's more common yeah
and
you know obviously that's a way of
bypassing some of these more primitive
emotions about jealousy etc and
leveraging them towards maybe even
ongoing relationships i'm not passing
judgment one way or the other i always
say
four conditions have to be met for any
discussion about about sex and sexuality
or sexual health age appropriate
context appropriate
consensual and species appropriate
well that that's weird because the thing
i'm trying to figure out is why my
sexual fantasy is to go to uh furry
orgies and have sex well with others
dressed as
squirrels
and me uh the other animals so that
could be that i have to i'll see a
therapist uh about that one okay
i'm not gonna respond to that except to
say that um as long as those four
conditions are met
yeah consensus
is right
so there's a bunch of questions on i uh
on instagram one of them
on this topic on relationships uh
somebody suggested to do a part three of
why lex is single there's a running joke
about this
uh so yeah
but i can answer it in part right yeah
because
well partially because you're very busy
partially because
you've decided that
until it's time you're gonna
wait until it's time it's time right i
mean until it's time you're waiting and
then um you're not saving yourself for
marriage uh i think but but in some
sense um yeah your your wife your future
wife is out there oh yeah yeah she's
being programmed no i uh i mean i
definitely i definitely believe that i
mean first of all i i just love people
and i fall in love very easily with
people with objects with things with
with life with every moment and that way
you're like oliver sacks he fell he
would fall in love with minerals
and concepts and things like that and so
like to me this kind of
uh so relationship is more like a
commitment to one particular kind of
um
object of your love
like uh it's almost like a
it's like a journey that you take on
together because also the interesting
thing about humans
is they're moment by moment a different
person day by day week by week month by
month they change they evolve there's an
ups and downs and stuff like that so
you're what you're doing is you're
saying well i'm going to explore all the
ways that this human gets
morphed and changed and the
what makes them cry what makes them
excited what makes them
uh lonely
like the
the the habits how like when they form
certain habits what
how they feel when those habits are
broken like the stupid my new things
that make everyday life you're gonna be
on that journey together figuring that
out just the way we're trying to figure
ourselves out when we're like optimizing
these things about diet and health so on
you're kind of doing this
computation together because neither
person really understands themselves
um at all and you're together both
confused about each other and you get to
almost like um
a relationship is a chance
to understand yourself
and
to understand another person
like together that process is some kind
of somehow
you know the dynamics right i mean
you're merging two nervous systems one
this was once described to me very well
by an ex-girlfriend um who's
truly brilliant she's really brilliant
um
she said you know there's four arrows
this is maybe to an engineer or like a
so make sense there's how you feel
towards the other person yes there's how
they feel towards you but then there's
an there's an arrow that comes back to
you
which is how you feel about how
they feel and then they have an arrow of
how they feel about how you feel right
this is why if someone else is moody or
somebody else is upset it
there's one version of ourselves where
we respond to that
or they respond to us but there's
another version where we respond to that
but it's also there's a processing of
what it means for us that they're
behaving that way or feeling that way
and this again
leads us back to that early attachment
circuitry because if a parent
was stressed
the child's role is not to soothe the
parent
in fact healthy models of parenting say
that children shouldn't actually know
how their parents feel for like the
first eight years of their life they're
not supposed to be in that mindset of
empathizing for the parent this is often
not the case but maybe the cutoff isn't
exactly eight but you get the idea so
the dynamics of a relationship are where
the learning is because we learn how we
react to other people reacting it's it's
not a just a two arrow system it's at
least this four-arrow thing um
but there's also the element of
nurturing right i mean i think that um
going through life with somebody is so
much better than going through it alone
and i i never thought i'd make that
statement um so it wasn't always obvious
to you no it wasn't always obvious to me
i've been i've really enjoyed wonderful
relationships um
and some have been hard and there's been
certainly been a lot of growth i'm on
good terms with almost all my
former girlfriends um and close with
some enough that i'm i know their
spouses and i'm close with their
families and um but no it wasn't and i
think that uh
when people say relationship is hard the
only really hard part about of a good
relationship is just dealing with
oneself and making sure that you're
staying in that
mode of caretaking because i do believe
that if
one is mainly focused on taking good
care of the other person provided
they're also
focused on taking good care of you to
some extent and we're good at taking
care of ourselves everybody flourishes
everything gets better but no i don't
think i experienced that until fairly
recently um what do you think is the uh
secret to a successful relationship
there isn't just one but at at least at
in the top five is
master or at least be
good at
autonomic self-regulation know how to
calm yourself down
don't expect the like looking to
anything external to soothe yourself is
it puts you in a terrible position to to
be a caretaker of yourself and other
people right so learn how to self soothe
right learn how to
calm your mind steady your actions
steady your voice there are tools to do
that we talk about in the podcast but
elsewhere have that in place i also
think that if
if your main focus is on you want to
have good boundaries etc but on
tending to the relationship doing a
little bit more than you think you ought
to do if everyone does that it goes
great i mean i'm sometimes so positively
struck by how supported i
feel um
because for many years i was just kind
of doing everything on my own so any
little thing i'm like oh my goodness
this feels huge um and also i think the
dynamics have to be right let's let's be
really honest this is a little bit of a
tricky topic but
um there is a power dynamic in
relationships
sometimes not all but in some
relationships it works much better if
one person leads and the other person
follows in other relationships it's more
mutuality works best people need to know
what they need and so knowing what you
need and what you crave
is really important and then once you do
that you can
create the relationship you want i've
seen that over and over again and people
are different
but i think that um
ultimately i mean right it's it's
there's the dopamine phase of a
relationship and then there's the
serotonin phase the kind of more
mutuality coziness and sweetness there's
a great book about how to make sure that
the dopamine component and the
serotonin component so to speak go on
forever and it has to do with you know
when you first meet someone you're
attracted to them you're essentially
objectifying them you meaning not in the
way people might think you are
not dependent on them for emotional
stability or survival as you get close
with somebody you really come to depend
on them and then you tend to objectify
them less and so this book the book is
the name is kind of corny but it's
written by an analyst again it's called
can love last and it's a book about how
really good strong relationships are the
consequence of people constantly moving
through this
dependency objectification dynamic
and i use those words in the true
the psychological sense not in the way
they're typically thrown around nowadays
so the id you know in some cultures
men and women
will
only touch for two weeks out of the
month
and then for the other two weeks
the
excitement and the sensuality and all
and the sexuality is very heightened
and then they go back to this kind of
distancing now i don't think that's
feasible for most people but if you look
statistically those relationships tend
to last a very long time with at least
reported
mutual feelings of intense attraction
for
many many many decades
so human beings need to learn how to
at least understand and control these
dynamics there's a lot of divorce
there's a lot of cheating there's a lot
of stuff out there it'd be great if
people could resolve some of this stuff
inside of the relationship in my opinion
yeah and this kind of intense attraction
i
uh actually uh one of the poems that
carl uh daiseroth introduced me to i
think two english poems is the name but
one of the
things i find myself for prolonged
periods being attracted to
is like
you notice some kind of magic
and you keep wanting to dig to the
depths like
of that magic trying to really know
to really know a person deeply yeah
you notice something yeah early on sure
i don't know what that is but you just
notice something special and you want to
keep pulling at that thread
and you never really do well you also
have to be careful you know i get a lot
of questions from god you have to be
careful the questions you ask in a
relationship too you have to make sure
you really want that information and
it's not just about people's past right
if you ask somebody how they really feel
about something about you and they tell
you
that may be soothing it may be intensely
stressful you have to be
here's one thing i know for sure for a
relationship to work you have to be
brave
you can't go in there fully protected
and yet you also can't go in there with
no boundaries because you'll end up
beat up what's that quote if you want to
be a warrior prepare to get hurt if you
want to be an explorer prepare to get
lost and if you want to be both you know
and if you become a lover prepare to
beat both or something something like
that i forget this is one of these
instagram type things that you see
passing by and you know that's pretty
true love love scary because it takes us
back to that primitive circuitry that is
as primitive and basic as hunger thirst
the desire for heat when we're cold the
desire for cold when we're overly warm
it's a
it's dinorphin i mean when somebody
leaves like the you know when somebody
you are attached to
leaves by death or by decision
or you're forced apart the dinorphin
release is a massive it is true
discomfort people
feel anxiety and discomfort and moving
through that is a hell of a process i
mean if i knew how to best break up at a
neurological level or if you just plug
yourself into a wall and reset
i mean i'd do that episode tomorrow but
we don't have that knowledge
come on the uh i think we've covered
this before and it's even been mummified
i think losing love is part of the magic
of love it means you've felt something i
agree but at some point like have you
done it enough times
you know
life is finite you know it is beautiful
to see these couples
that seem very much in love
despite
many years despite having been together
many years yeah the way they look at
each other yeah they'll say they still
see the magic yeah and they'll say we
got lucky or it was it's been hard or
this and that i think external
conditions being a little tougher
is helpful for a couple
hardship i do i do because i think that
you rally you know you you and you bond
with people you know being obviously you
want to survive those conditions but um
yeah i do i think that bonnie and clyde
so and they were a little
a little too much
well a little bit too much they were
sociopaths but the uh
well when two sociopaths finally can
make you do crazy normally it's
interesting normally sociopaths don't
team up
because they because they manipulate
each other
sociopaths sadly are um are usually only
interested in manipulating the highly
pliable or unsuspecting
um
but when romantic attraction is woven in
then it gets
um
really diabolical any advice on finding
the love of your
life of my life this is this is uh why
lex's single response why any advice
yeah actually this comes from a friend
of mine who's in a really excellent
marriage um with great kids and family
and high demand life
it it's a decision like at some point
you just priority you just prioritize it
as okay
i'm going to make this happen one way or
another and um you don't force the
discovery of that person but i mean i've
occasionally said hey i think you should
meet this person or that person and um
well it wasn't maybe my judgment was
might have been off but it the timing
wasn't right or something but i think
that yeah it's a decision
and it also has to do with life
structure i mean there were years so i
when i was in graduate school i didn't
want a girlfriend i just wanted to be in
lab and i sure i had romantic dating
interests but i wasn't going to meet
them through a committed you know live
together situation wasn't where i was at
and as a postdoc here things are a
little different etc etc so but at some
point it's sort of like what do i want
my daily routine to look like because
ultimately a relationship
however one structures is gonna be part
of your daily routine so at the point
where you're like you know i'd really
love to wake up next to somebody and do
blank and blank together and then i'd
love to
work and then we meet for dinner and
then we you know take the dog for a walk
or take kids out or whatever it happens
to be take a trip but do you have to be
one has to be in the mindset of wanting
to do couple like things yeah people and
a lot of people don't think about it
that way they they either fall into
something
or they
they don't see the benefits of
coupling up i think that the pandemic
tuned people's awareness to
the fact that some things are indeed
easier on your own
it depends on finances etc etc but
a lot of things are made better
done with other people
100 percent but i also so
i was very deliberately
it's an interesting way to put it like
what do you want your day to look like i
think what what do you want your day to
look like what you want your life to be
i was very deliberately always
uh first of all
happy to be alone
like a conscious thinking
i know a lot of friends were just unable
to be alone i'm able to be alone but i'm
much happier with another person like
i'm able to share joy with other humans
i look forward to the day that our kids
are rolling jiu-jitsu and my kids are
you know
hanging out with your kids and um if
that notion sounds
even remotely interesting then
and fun then then it's sort of like you
kind of backpedal from that and you go
how do you guys
first engineer and think from first
principles about love
andrew you're uh
thank you for being my friend thank you
for being an amazing human being who's
so inspiring to so many people for
constantly i i told this to carl like
one of the things that was really
refreshing um about you
is that
you uh
when i tell you an idea and i tell you a
thought when i tell you something
you didn't you you don't
shut it down as a first step i'm saying
that that's common in scientific
community that's commonly people around
you you're you're seeing what's the goal
there you get excited you get excited
together and that's how you can really
uh have a great friendship and a great
do create great stuff together so i i'm
deeply grateful for that and just
uh for connecting so many interesting
people together you're doing an amazing
job man and uh thank you for existing
thank you for being here thank you for
talking today and uh next time i'll see
you in the sauna and yeah yeah thanks
beth well i want to say several things
first of all thank you for having me on
again it's an honor and a pleasure i
don't say that formally i really truly
mean it i only the huberman lab podcast
as i always say only exists because you
gave me the suggestion
and i'm so grateful that you did so
thank you and
for doing what you do like you you are
brave and your first man in and you're
just continue to do it just what as my
postdoc advisor used to say whatever
you're doing just keep going
and then in terms of our friendship i
mean i think uh
you know and if you uh if you don't i'm
gonna just keep telling you anyway by
texting in person you're an amazing
friend uh there's deep trust there's
immense respect
and uh
i love you brother i love you too man
we did it
thanks for listening to this
conversation with andrew huberman to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
ralph waldo emerson
it is one of the blessings of old
friends
you can afford to be stupid with them
i look forward to doing just that
in the many years to come
a friendship and fun conversations with
andrew
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time